foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
check check mic check mic check
I don't know about you guys but I'm not
tired of this music yet
even now I'm I'm not tired of it yet
and I don't think I'll get tired of it
to be honest with you guys
I don't think I will
Mike is checked Mike is locked
and we are ready
to roll
[Music]
oh yeah Lauren I always keep people on
their toes
that countdown timer is you know it's
just a number
just a number
Moon Lily how excited am I I you know I
haven't watched in the past few years so
I'm I'm actually pretty pretty curious
to see
what the state of the industry is
looking like right now as a whole
but I'm glad they talked about how the
timing was cut down significantly
shorter which I am I was glad to hear
that because it I mean it was like over
three hours long the past couple years
which is just way too long
so I haven't watched in a while but yeah
I'm honestly I'm more excited to hang
out with you guys hang out with James
we're gonna hop in a call with James
here in a bit
yeah just just a number just a number
oh my gosh we're getting really good
with timing that intro
timing that Hogwarts Legacy music right
at the point when we are starting the
stream going live
how's everybody doing tonight welcome
all right so
the pre-show is getting ready to start
actually I'm just gonna go ahead and
completely bypass this screen right here
I'm just gonna go ahead and kill the
Spotify music as well
because uh yeah so this is like the
pre-show
which I'm actually gonna turn it down
just a bit
but yeah we're gonna we're gonna do
intros here we'll let the pre-show start
I don't think there's gonna be anything
super major happening during the
pre-show we'll kind of just let it roll
in the background there and then uh say
hi to everybody and then we'll we'll hop
in a call with James expect to go if you
guys aren't uh familiar with him I feel
like most of you here are hanging out
right now already know James but if you
don't
James aka the Merlin conspiracy theorist
AKA
expecto go
he's live over on his Channel right now
also on YouTube
and we're just going to be hanging out
in a call together throughout the awards
tonight
and let's see who we got here let's see
who we got tonight we got Noob of course
Noob is back in the house welcomed Noob
and Alicia I mean it's only fitting that
Noob and Alicia are the first two names
that I see
by the way if you guys didn't see the
Hogwarts Legacy jump button I mean
Alicia and I with with all of your help
and also the help of Thor's hammer we
made that happen we made that happen
Elwyn is here Reva called Tyrell wizard
sorry I missed your uh Super Chat right
at the end uh Ravenclaw Tyrell all right
let's hear let's hear what they have to
say here at the beginning
ax
applause applause
it's like DLC that you play before you
play vanilla we've got exclusive content
Awards we might just have to skip the
intros tonight guys
might just have to skip it
hot dog I haven't seen that name in a
while welcome my friend
Shadow guided Noisy Boy go ninja go
around the world to millions and our Big
Show Noob with the five gifted
where we will honor their best gaming
has to offer often with new looks
uh yeah Ellen slow mode oh no slow modes
it's not enabled because I set it up as
a uh much more hold on I might be able
to
[Music]
see if we can turn it on after the fact
[Music]
how are you okay stream settings
viewer activity nope stream Health nope
shopping I don't think I can do it once
we're live
I don't think I can do it once we've
already started unfortunately
welcome to Griffin most everybody in
here right now is a member of House
Dragon tour anyway
[Music]
I'm not seeing it
oh well hopefully it won't be too bad
hopefully hopefully
all right so let's see Noob with the
five gifted right there Noob thank you
so much for the five gifted looks like
Felix Bryant uh Talon pineapple Sam Tom
and oh then Dylan with the 10 super chat
smash that like button Dylan thank you
so much man fellow member of House
wrecking tour moderator here on the
stream as well then we got psycho
jumping in there with the five dollar
Super Chat psycho welcome back good to
see you my friend after the game comes
out in all possible content has been
made what's the plan for videos in the
future
that's what I'm trying to figure out
psycho that's that's what I'm figuring
out right now
um probably a more General look at the
gaming industry
and video game news that sort of thing
but I but I have some ideas for some
like some Staples of the channel and
then I really want to get back into
streaming games regularly again but I
feel like this show right here this live
show
I feel like it's going to be a staple
for me and for the channel for a long
time probably just uh we'll just shift
into more like gaming news of course
World premiere
and then elwind with wait wait Casey
with the two dollar Super Chat CT scan
went well
so happy to hear it Casey so happy to
hear it I know that's a big relief for
you
and then uh two dollar Super Chat oh
wait we gotta make sure we don't miss
best and most anticipated
Darren Jesper Darren welcome to the
stream thank you so much for the two
dollar Super Chat and then Elle went
jumping in there with the five gifted
memberships
[Music]
Ahmad epic and Stevie magic arachnid hot
dog and John dingus
all getting a gift of membership right
now right now right there
I'm keeping this low right now guys this
is just a pre-show it's all good then we
got Nico jumping in with a super chat
welcome all new members of house rack
and tour I forgot the hammer tonight man
I forgot the hammer and then Noob with
another Super Chat
Noob thank you so much for the support
for the Super Chat house record tour
welcome you all welcome you all and
all right you know what I'm gonna grab
the hammer though I'm gonna grab the
hammer I don't feel like the hammer
literally
created with the power of of myself
Alicia and the combined forces of the
chat
channeling through Thor's hammer we made
the Hogwarts Legacy jump button happen
we made it happen
yeah and now buckle up for three World
premieres in a row so tonight
first is a game that is out here we go
we're gonna have it close by
we're gonna have it close by
they did already get up give out an
award
yeah they start uh like in the pre-show
here oh wait World premiere hold on hold
on hold on see what we got here
okay mobile game
I don't know about you guys I'm not I'm
not too big into mobile games
all right uh Nico thanks so much for the
Super Chat and Noob as well
all right let me send James a message I
want to let James know I feel like he's
probably done with his
pre-show by now
ready when you are
two brothers fight to survive the
mjolnar is out it's getting serious
right
yeah so I gotta I'll talk to James about
that I don't know if he saw my clip
I've already gotten some requests by the
way I've gotten some requests to
try and see if we guys as a as a chat if
we can combine our forces once again to
make swimming a reality that's that's
been the next request
so we'll see how tonight goes what
tonight brings but I don't know man I
don't know I I feel like I feel like
there's still a little magic left
in the hammer here I feel like we can
make some other magic happen
we don't even know if there's going to
be Hogwarts Legacy News Tonight by the
way folks we're just we're just hanging
out
we'll just see what happens
I mean we know for sure
Eternal PC okay nice nice nice love I
love Eternal I was a big fan of Eternal
actually
early 2023.
I cannot wait for these games to come
out that's a good question go ninja
gifted a membership how do I continue it
you would probably have to let it expire
and once it expires I bet you could
start a new membership
con ninja who is going to show us a new
way Ninja
was it another mobile thing
all right James is ready let me see if I
can call him in here
mike check mic check yo there we go can
you hear us we serious man
can you hear me okay yeah yeah I can
hear you chat let me know if you can
hear retro
let me know uh I'm assuming I'm live
over on a retro record choice
indeed
crazy right this is so crazy oh my gosh
yo is Sue with you James she is not yet
okay yes I would have her say hi but uh
everybody yo we got thumbs UPS in the
chat we got Yo Retros and now chat what
about you
same here same here looks like they can
hear you loud and clear I gotta tell you
I'm a little I'm a little nervous about
meeting Sue I uh I saw the the clip
about the kill Mary kiss and ever since
that I'm a little worried you know I
hope there's no there's no awkwardness
between Sue and I
uh retro I think you'll be good
oh I think you'll be good I think you'll
be good I'm gonna lower uh the stream a
little bit so everybody can hear you oh
my gosh so uh retro uh they just showed
mobile game awards just one uh Marvel
snap just awarded to best mobile game
have you heard of that has that been on
your radar what are you thinking I have
not I was telling chat I'm not I don't
really play Too Many mobile games how
about you
um I outside Wizards unite of course
right right outside of wizards unite
um yeah I played Pokemon go I still play
that because that's Niantic I I still
play that but yeah outside of that
nothing really and what's funny is like
I remember when I when I got my first
iPhone it was just like I was blown away
at the games you could play on there and
then I don't know just something like
over the years as I got older I just
stopped playing I mean there's a lot of
good mobile games I don't want to hate
on mobile games as a whole but I just
heard maybe it's a Time thing like when
I play it's just like you know what I'd
rather sit down and put some time into
God of War or something
speaking of games we got best fighting
game up right now who do you think
you're gonna get it oh
multiverses yeah I was gonna say gut
reaction multiverses yeah
let's see
oh the stream is low yeah sorry I forgot
to turn there it is there it is so yours
already okay I'm gonna refresh mine then
because mine am I a hit I think we're
caught up I think yeah okay okay
that's so James and I tested before we
went live and I was actually head of
James but now it seems are you still on
The Game Spot one or did you switch to
the official switch to the official one
ah okay okay yeah I was testing I was
testing on The Game Spot one but now I'm
on the official one all right I'm there
sifu is a great game I just know
multiverses like a lot of people that's
that's been killing it for whatever
reason
keep waiting dude I'm like WB come on
Harry Potter put him in put him in hold
up what is the hold up oh my gosh but yo
oh you think we're getting a trailer yes
or no
I feel like we are
did you see the pictures of Chandler
online yeah they're out there right yeah
yeah they're there they're there with a
couple of other cats uh you saw him buy
behind the scenes videos so oh we got a
trailer
yeah let's see this here yeah
I'm gonna turn up the stream guys yeah
yeah I know it was a lowercase Logan
what's up man appreciate you yes I had
it low so you could hear James and I
around
or if you were talking about a different
volume oh Hellboy
I'm loving this style yes
yeah that's Hellboy
yo
What type of game is this
me dude it looks like uh that Wolf Among
Us or Matt oh my goodness you remember
mad world yeah oh my gosh yes
yes that's a deep cut right there yes
mad world oh my gosh this is a Wii right
yeah great callback oh my gosh you
pulled that one out of it oh
something about this style though
if blood goes everywhere oh there we go
how do you pronounce weird
wired weird
hey you know I have such a good track
record with pronunciations I have to be
very careful with the chat am I right
uh Johnny boy said they thought it was a
wolf game over here oh Wolf Among Us
yeah yeah so yeah
the nominees Esports I know nothing
about Esports
I'll say it happened I was gonna say
Valerie
did you get that quick yeah I was gonna
say about it too they did that one quick
yeah
don't know I'll say uh Faker I don't
know any of those people neither do I
yay yay yay new sports team yeah Casey
uh Hellboy game
face right face phase is pretty pretty
uh popular okay there we go loud oh wow
I haven't heard of them
uh Robin score I'll say score because
it's all been on the bottle darn it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm gonna say League of Legends yeah
League of Legends
oh yeah
let's go
you think they're gonna do most
anticipated before or are they gonna do
it live I think it's got to be it's got
to be live
right
I guess this is live too right this is
just yeah this is a pre-show okay yeah
I can't remember mirrors and only a
little bit more time let's get right to
three more starting with wait how many
more 15 minutes okay here we go which is
up for game of the year Horizon also won
an award as part of horizon DLC
yeah they mentioned that right DLC I
think so
oh this is a
psvr
wow yo I need to get that I wish it
wasn't as expensive I would love to get
that with my I would love to have that
because the game is gorgeous it is I
need to play the new one
I played the first one loved it yeah I
have the new one I my back my back stock
of games is just ridiculous save I was
so like behind I was gonna talk to you
about that actually because I'm like I
feel like since I started really doing
lots of YouTube my gaming has plummeted
oh my actual gaming literally that is me
like verbatim I'm like I don't spend
time playing games it's not coming up
with the video yeah trying to come up
with a concept so yeah I'm with you man
you're not alone
how much is the psvr by the way
they're about to come out with that new
one next early next year
it wasn't even like more expensive than
like the PlayStation or as expensive I
think I have no idea I bet somebody in
chat knows Jay at a chat how much is the
uh Playstation VR moonla you'd break
your TV playing this in VR
that face no way they would they
wouldn't reveal it all pre-show no no no
no he looks like him now
post trauma what
coming to PC console wishlist on Steam
oh mind games are you a horror guy I'm
not much
no my I got a bad part
I can't handle jump scare oh man yeah I
don't I always say that but then I tell
people I love bloodborne I love Resident
Evil for yeah yeah but just like the
pure
like Outlast or something I no the ones
that are just out to scare you and
nothing else I'm not big on those
asthmophobia exactly yeah I can't I
can't I can't do it I cannot do it so
before we got we got like a uh just
under uh 13 minutes yeah so
game of the year
what is yours I mean see that that's why
I was asking about how many games you
played this year because I I mean it's
Elder ring for me but I haven't played
Ragnarok yet and I I really love the
first one I haven't played Horizon so I
stopped playing ghost of tsushima just
to do Ragnarok just because just because
like everybody and I knew I would be
able to like play through that pretty
fast because it's more linear then it
goes to sushima
um God Ragnarok just is it pretty good
yeah but I didn't finish Elder ring
because I had just got it when I got my
PS5 so you I might have more insight on
the Elder ring aspect than I would I'd
be shocked if Elder ring didn't win
because it I mean a lot of people are so
sick of talking about it now but I feel
like it was the one game that it had so
much hype and it actually lived up to it
which is so hard yeah yeah and I feel
like it was on not just gaming
communities but hey what's up man
everybody was talking about ordering
like I can't see that we should get it
we got to work into my chat over here uh
but yeah I I just think just based off
everybody's reactions like eldering just
didn't miss yeah Casey in my chat says
Hogwarts Legacy is going to win
I don't think it's up for that one yet
Casey maybe next year you never know
yeah yo next year is going to be stiff
competition Zelda Hogwarts Legacy uh
Spider-Man 2 like it's going to be it's
gonna be crazy I'm going to pass on this
yeah did you see my uh clip about the
jump button yeah was that not crazy yo
yo they they're listening they're
listening that whole stream like my chat
was going on and on about the jump
button and I was like I really don't
think it's saying guys but if you want
me to summon all my my Powers right now
we all have to you know group thoughts
together we can make this happen and
then next day
the next day I was like yeah chat you
guys are wondering how we got that clip
uh just shout out retro in his uh
Tuesday's live stream chat they all just
came together like Goku with the Spirit
Bomb so now people have been asking me
to do one for swimming so I mean now we
got we got James on the other line guys
we've got both of our chats the power
combined mjolnir here maybe maybe we can
make swimming happen we'll see yes chat
we gotta summon it we have to summon
that we're getting swimming either
tonight or next week that's where that's
that's the window
we're getting swimming was it you who
brought it up
also won this game
even though it looks crazy
it's kind of an interesting art style
here yeah
so what are your kids into right now
because you and I both have kids almost
the exact same age yep yep yep
um Pokemon that's it come on Pokemon
whether it's the main Series game
Scarlet Violet whether it's
um what's this the battle one I forgot
what it's called
um that one where you can like play with
other people and then they'll go back
and play some of my old Pokemon games
and stuff and then Raven called Tyrell
with this one everywhere gifteds as well
thank you so much
right quick
Tyrell gifting in both streams let's go
all right so guys while James is muted
for a second how's audio on everything
you guys hear James okay I know the
actual game awards is low right now I'm
gonna keep that lower and then when we
actually start for real James and I are
gonna be talking as much just let me
know how all the audio is thank you guys
yeah ravaculty real gift I think he
timed his gift right at the same time
how are you he gifted over here too oh
my gosh I muted myself
oh yeah all good I've been trying to
mute two every now and then so I'm not
wearing your chat out no you're good
you're good you're good you're good
you're good but yeah show some love uh
yo this house is in the chat right now
showing some love nice thank you that
one awesome it's so cool with the
community because we do know like Harry
Michael roses everybody watches each
other congrats guys so it's just so cool
to see like everybody supporting
everybody like that for sure yep
so yeah you're saying your your kids
Pokemon my my oldest he's finally
started to get into fortnite
and he's like he's so I won't let him
play online with people yet he's he's
eight so we right I try to play with him
or he's like playing solo and I'm like
in the room watching him or something
but I mean it is it's amazing how that
game just
whether you're young old it just it hits
a certain note and he's loving it he's
having so much fun with it that's
awesome and they just came out with the
new
um I think an Unreal Engine 5 that's
coming out with it yeah like their their
latest update it runs a lot better now
and looks better too on a lot of systems
man as are we get Majestic
over here uh let me see dang James look
good brother looking like a snazzy puff
thanks I was dancing with the super oh I
got a full are you all dressed up on
stream oh oh yeah yeah
somebody told me Lynette was dressed up
she was I'm so underdressed I'm just
like rocking the black shirt and a hat
go go just find a blaze and throw it on
it we'll we'll be looking like
presenters in no time like yeah I I like
when I got off the phone with you
earlier I was just like I gotta change
and then I just thought I was like yo
let me just see what happens so I had a
Blazer and it's such a good idea yeah
for the game awards I didn't do it last
year or the previous year but I was like
yo this year let's let's do it
especially if Hogwarts Legacy is here so
yeah hey Dylan says we we should do a
live stream let's play We we've talked
about that yeah we've been throwing back
and forth some ideas
yes yes this is not the last one this is
the first of many but if you guys have
any suggestions or ideas throw them all
away because uh we're trying to come up
with some good stuff uh just to show
some love to the community and have some
fun with ourselves and the other
creators so yeah that would be so much
thank you for the stupid
right right
I love that and then we both get YouTube
videos out of it like I raced retro
wrecking tour in Hogwarts Legacy yeah
well at least like it doesn't have to be
a whole game to be the first one to ride
buckbeat you know if that's where we are
yeah
that would be so dope first one to AKA
Poppy
I shouldn't have said it I'm probably
derailing both of our chats by saying
that
oh my God all right so we got five
minutes here World premiere premiere
T-minus five
this looks like some old school Graphics
yeah
Phoenix
Patrol Logan thanks for the Super Chat
do we know if progress Legacy is using a
real engine
um we don't know if he's using five yet
foreign
what is this
[Music]
sad cat Studios never familiar with him
yeah
I'm liking this style though so side
scrolling yeah the old 2D joints yeah
Nico thanks for the Super Chat love the
scarf Shades Nico appreciate you for
trying to Squad
we don't know when they're gonna show
Hoggers Legacy yet do you think they
would get it during the stream it's got
to be during the actual show now right
because it was less than five yeah five
yeah
[Music]
I mean we know for sure we'll at least
see something when they pull up for the
right right most anticipated yep yep yep
yep
so at least see that hey psycho I'm
calling it will have multiplayer dueling
DLC
thank you for the Super Chat psycho I'd
love that I think the main villain or
whatever
oh my gosh Noob just sent the same thing
to me in a Super Chat
[Laughter]
oh my gosh thank you guys man thank you
and if you haven't already be sure to go
subscribe to Russia rocket tour you
already know the deal bringing you guys
like everything he loves storytelling
right back at you
okay so they are gonna do some more
rewards here right before the start this
is gonna be cute
okay so family game interesting what are
the nominees yeah I don't even remember
seeing these
maybe some Nintendo stuff
probably
oh my kids love Kirby oh Lego Star Wars
Splatoon
Splatoon was later
Mario and Rabbids I'm going to predict
Star Wars I'm gonna say Splatoon
I forgot to switch Sports
[Applause]
I still stick with a Splatoon
Kirby
oh we were both wrong
it's really good both my kids have been
playing that one yeah it's really cute I
need to download that recognition I'm
accepting this on behalf of this that's
Doug Bowser yeah Laboratories and
Nintendo that worked on Kirby is that
what he got the name browser from
it's honestly unreal that dude's name is
Bowser
he works his way up to be the seat
president
there you go thanks again guys really
appreciate it thank you
Kelly over here called it somebody did
you say Tom over here say you look like
Bruce Willis who does a trip a franchise
that has been around for 35 years and
still going strong has interesting oh
you called it over here Moon Lily nice
from Street Fighter 6. whoa Street
Fighter what
thanks Jenna
I haven't played a Street Fighter game
and I don't know how long I think Marvel
versus Street Fighter was the last
episode
on the Dreamcast oh Dreamcast yeah yeah
I can't believe this game is still alive
it's crazy
same with Mortal Kombat yep I was about
to say Mortal Kombat
Castle fighting games
it looks better I've always been more of
like a Smash Bros kind of fighting game
instead of yeah
I'm with you I was heavy into Tekken
three way in a pretty popular one mm-hmm
but yeah the wave of fighting games
looks to be like a Smash Brothers or
multiverses
I feel like it's so like that genre is
just perfect for like the free to play
yeah I know a lot of people hate free to
play but
I mean I still I feel like fortnite does
it as good as you can do it they figured
it out yep they figured it out epic game
yep they figured it out over there
pass and skip a lot of passes I didn't
know Chandler was going to the game Wars
he is feathers he's there with Eric and
doing a bunch of tweeted about it yep
yep he's tweeted about it
when I saw that I thought does that mean
that they because I wonder if they get a
heads up on you're gonna win this yeah
yeah but I know stuff like that they
might just get invites oh yeah they
might just send it to Avalanche software
all the nominees yep yep yep yep yep and
like hey come hang out this is the first
in-person one in the wild too that's
true okay so any fighting games minimal
fighting game fans here but yeah it's
been a minute since they were just like
yo come and buy tickets go ninja says
Mortal Kombat J Rossi UFC WWE whether a
win or a trailer but I'm not sure
oh yeah I was about to say this earlier
and I got they started showing something
um all right see I messaged James
yesterday I guess when the jump button
thing got announced and I said I wonder
if this means they're showing something
tonight it's gonna have jumping in it so
they thought hey it'll be fun to go
ahead and tell them about the jump
button today and then we'll have the big
trailer tomorrow where you see us
jumping in it yeah
am I reading way too much into it yes
probably but that's what we do we do
that's exactly what we do
I think we might get some ccxp stuff hey
or at least an extended scene or
something like the Sebastian thing like
they got a show though that grab porn
Mount some point yes they gotta show
that in high quality for all of us let's
see all right Chad here we go let's go
let's go welcome to the game awards
now here's your host the creator of the
game suits
yeah he's done such a good job with this
yes I haven't watched in years but
he's been branching out to like welcome
to the game awards everybody in
different mediums and stuff so the fans
and to have the entire industry with us
here tonight here we go
we're starting with Hogwarts Legacy oh
my God I would lose my mind
mute and the rest of the stream it's
just us talking about it we don't even
watch the game awards I will cut it in a
heart
foreign
[Applause]
immortality welcome to the game awards
yo that suit is tough right
and of course we have Phil Spencer from
Xbox with us welcome Phil ew I think
Reggie's there too but yeah I know you
saw him accepting an award already in
the opening act
and that was there
Bruce Willis of course last year's Game
of the Year winner Joseph Ferris is back
wait who won going for the year last
year
guys that that
game with two people
oh yeah yeah the the couple's joint oh
yes oh I forgot it was the name I forgot
what it's called I know exactly what
you're talking about I won a lot of
awards
world thank you for being a part of this
I remember and show you what somebody in
chat is gonna beat us to it it takes two
Sharon got it dude there it is
Survivor this is a big one
an update on thanks Maddie yep take two
that's most anticipated the clip from
the Super Mario Brothers movie oh I
can't wait for the Super Mario clip and
oh yes that movie looks amazing game
announcements and surprises trust me
we've got a lot of things no leaks we're
very excited about what we're about to
share with you guys
it's time for our first award to present
it I am so anticipated let's go
please join me and welcome back to the
game awards
Al Pacino oh my goodness oh my gosh
how'd he do that
reminds me acting like wow
my Cheeto what
so what thank you
that's a big get that is a huge gift
it's for Chino
Wow Let Me Find Out Pacino wants to play
hogways Legacy
as usual oh my gosh how much did he did
he get paid for this oh dude anyway
uh I I maybe Keanu put in a good word
that's right he was there last year
that's right I forgot about that but uh
I I I I it's hard for me to see the
teleprompter anyway
[Laughter]
he just admits
try don't play a whole lot of video
games
I like the honesty yes yes I have
however spent a lot of time watching my
kids play
and there you go there you go to be
thoroughly impressed and uh
um entertained you
know oh this is great and all but he's
no Chandler wood oh my goodness
hey that's what we all about here retro
racquet tour
and the stories that's right
by the performance
oh so is this performance oh nomination
uh because as an actor I've learned that
whether you're on a stage
we're almost exactly on the same time
I'm hearing your audio just a little bit
in the background it's not bad but just
like a little guy always okay
fundamentally
uh we we are all trying to tell a story
and I want to tell a story hmm uh and
the next greatest story is Hogwarts
Legacy
that's what I'm waiting for like come on
come on tie it in to celebrate the
achievements cheap of these he's
struggling he is
my breathing life into these I mean he's
got to be pretty up there now too oh
yeah oh yeah maybe in my video games to
a new height
um
clap clap yeah that's a clap right there
no I'm looking at a Al Pacino age or the
best performance of the year
oh this is best for four okay
Christopher Judge yeah yeah performance
that makes sense so Pacino to do it yeah
oh the kid is up
to
Andreas
yeah I don't know their real names yeah
somebody from God of War
I'm working out now this is heavy
finally I didn't work out today so I'm
doing you don't mind do you if I yeah I
think Christopher Judge guys that would
be my pick the best
Christopher
yeah
yeah let's go let's go yes God Maddie
that is Al Pacino just Google them
huge he's huge
no explanation oh man he's already
getting emotional you can see yeah yeah
I saw where he said he'd love to play
him if they ever did like a live action
he'd do awesome too
right yeah it would be so weird
because I know Jason Momoa was uh wanted
to do it uh somebody else
and probably as an actor that's huge for
him to be getting an award from Al
Pacino all right
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
now I see why I couldn't get more than a
plus one
um
thank you he is of course
big guy who is cyberpunk Dustin yeah I
have to thank my mama
um
shout out to all the moms
who's
belief that I would amount to something
good would uh never waver even though it
looked like I'd never amount to anything
good
my brother
who's my hero
man 40. you could tell I mean this voice
shakes the Earth right
went to medical school and is now Dr
Judge
nice nice
so the kid that was by him that's atreus
yeah right okay yeah
[Applause]
who I am forever
proud of
forever thankful of oh man and still the
best role I've ever had is being your
dad
oh man he's cutting to our hearts now
wow oh wow
[Applause]
Sony Santa Monica
[Applause]
Miss Yumi yang
it is an honor and a pleasure
to work
for you and with you you are a unicorn
because you how do you pronounce it Mr
Sunny for the first time ever Sunny with
trickle-down Theory actually is so wrong
Corey barlog thank you brother
yeah I guess Corey probably the one who
thank you found him originally
believing in me and thank you for having
me read for the role
um yeah there you go Adam Reed who's the
last actor in California to read for it
um wow and Corey
said to me he didn't think I would do it
and uh if I had known it was a video
game back then I might not have
boy oh wow wow
Matt wow rich
so he didn't even know it was a game
going in
that's crazy
that's crazy oh
oh everyone
who made that just don't drop that
trophy all right I'm so sacred
yeah
everyone
at every level
be a designer be it whatever it was who
worked was who worked under
extraordinary conditions
to get this game out
Came Of The Year somebody yelled better
world can't we skin
Mr Eric Williams it's like can we get to
the Hogwarts Legacy stuff
uh I I think it's kind of common I
wonder if they do have them on a timer
right if they're like to go to Tribeca
after 2018.
and When Corey took me outside and said
he wouldn't be directing the next one I
literally did quit
I quit no way and he said no
I vouch for Eric
and I said
Eric Williams better be a beast
foreign
Eric Williams is a [ __ ] Beast
oh man
he's a beast
in my chat they say uh Damien said he's
definitely a Hufflepuff
my chat was saying Slytherin I don't
think Slytherin
Eric Williams and I
or no you guys are saying Slytherin
about uh Al Pacino my fault my fault my
fault two different my chat was saying
Slytherin for Al Pacino my fault okay
okay
oh yeah I agree with you chat hey Chad
Al Pacino Slytherin or something else
I'll never forget oh yeah and sorry for
the we normally keep it family friendly
as everybody knows but uh I can't help
that one tonight guys yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and if you guys can live yeah
sorry any kids you might wanna
right now yeah
hopefully apologies on our normal
schedules you'll be good but something
like this yeah and I I reel it in
and Eric came over to me
and he's about to start just hug me I
know
I wonder if they have him on a timer
they might not they might not expected
this I know because he's been here for
like five minutes
okay I mean clearly a very moving yeah
speech
you gotta get it out of him I don't
blame him at all yeah
you don't want them to get music off
I know they're gonna start the music
who
brought as much or more true Al pacita
just standing there that is true
I mean we were in there hey Ellen it's
all good you could you could let those
slide it's fine I get it people are
ready you know people get ready to move
on heartache their loves their lost
loves their loneliness
I am so grateful and thankful
that
Jeff keeley's probably like uh
the show's not gonna be as short as I
thought oh they just getting started
yeah I think I hear music
this is it's a big award for him now
yeah for sure this is a big award I
wasn't lying I voted for you
okay your work was somebody's coming on
stage
you're the future of this that's the
cameraman it's never
forget
the two things I hopefully gave you
hire me
don't be a douchebag
[Applause]
oh man
to every single person in this room no
matter what game it was you touched you
are heroes because you got so many
people in the world through a very
difficult dark time that's still not
over a true true
games in The Gaming Community well there
is somebody behind him up there in
Vietnam yeah yeah in the course of
dreams and escapism and and just
being better
um thank you thank you to the rest of
the nominees
have a great night
and I met Al Pacino oh that was Al up
there I thought it was somebody coming
to be like okay I was like yo I've been
in a bunch of these you got to go homie
oh that's right
I'm not even in there I need to pull
that stream up studios are here at the
awards to give you a glimpse at the
exciting future of video games in 2023
and beyond our first world premiere is a
small but highly acclaimed Studio that
needs no introduction at this point and
whose last game earned multiple Awards
here at TGA I'm very excited to share
the global announcement of their next
project Here We Go Global announcement
okay
I thought it was that's what a second I
know I know I'm a mute trailer
super giant okay okay
snuggle it was pretty long I'm happy
he's happy
I know Jeff's Ryan Jeff's like
all right we gotta speed it up now
oh dude this art style let's go
let's go
supergiant makes some really good games
too
I'm curious to see if it's the same
style as some of the others
the others have kind of this like
isometric
it's like sort of top down but at an
angle
good yo what is this
not good enough
we can but learn
the greatest
Hades music oh is this
death to Christmas
is this a sequel to Hades
oh let's go
I need to play that to make a better
future at least I can do is lot your way
down
about ready to give in no
no just the art style is so good
most anticipated a new game likely at
the end
right
dude Ellen the the Bots are out tonight
huh
I don't know
that's Zeus
cannot be stopped Zeus a good guy in
this
I'll be this
I don't know why the uh Bots are getting
through tonight Owen sorry about that
but I'm glad you're I'm glad you're
catching the messages
nightbot should get them
Hades two is the next game just getting
started people now in development at
supergiant games like the original which
was revealed here at TGA in 2018. Hades
2 is going to be developed in Early
Access so your feedback can help shape
I've heard nothing but good things about
Hades 23.
next I'm so excited about this one we're
taking a journey to an exciting New
World with a world premiere from a
studio led by someone with a legacy of
building incredible oh my gosh he said
Legacy
and creating genre defining experiences
it's moments like this not as though get
me excited about the future of our
medium
you don't think so I don't think so
I hope I'm wrong no it's not okay okay
here darn it yeah Bioshock creators of
Bioshock dad
dude they had me going for a second when
he said Legacy
man Bioshock is so good
let's see is it any gameplay or just
just like cut scenes
[Music]
oh dude this looks so much like BioShock
not just from the makers of BioShock
you can see the inspiration
people say
she kind of looks like that uh
girl from the last BioShock
Judas what
fix what you broke
okay Judas is the name fix what you
broke
could you surprises tonight that was a
first look at Judas coming from Ghost
Story games led by Ken Levine do you
play Bioshock James yeah way back yeah
way back yeah
you can definitely see this see The
Inspirations yes yes for sure approaches
to narrative that you will learn about
in the future let me just say I can't
wait for them to tell you more didn't
that look fantastic
getting a new Mass event game too all
right well let's go to another brand new
game announcement for the fans here at
the game awards
it's a brand new game though yeah it's
not us
oh switch okay switch
yo another Bayonetta
in the third when to the third one
didn't it come out this year
Elizabeth yes yes yes that was her name
maybe it's just the art style like the
art style looks so much like BioShock
Bayonetta Origins
wait what
that is not what bandana looks like
what is this
[Music]
oh people are gonna be so upset
if they were wanting a
an actual Bayonetta game
oh I guess so it's kind of like more
like that Hades Style
sort of isometric top down
[Music]
oh dude I think
I think Bayonetta fans are going to be
upset it's my guess I'm just guessing
though
[Music]
play as cereza before she lost her
memory ah okay see I don't know all the
yeah I definitely do not know any of the
Bayonetta lore just
[Music]
we got trolled by
[Music]
I thought didn't he just like was
Bayonetta three was it this year
and the lost demon
March 17th
oh you and K ghost if they announced
that would be one of my favorite
announcements from this is if they
announced a new Switch
oh I would love that so much
okay that was a little surprising
Adventure game in the banana series on
March the 17th all right I'm not a
Bayonetta player but seeing that I was
like people are gonna be disappointed
and it's not a true Bayonetta yeah yeah
and steam Val was giving away a
week that's crazy but I probably should
start talking a little quicker after
Chris's speech but I'm so glad that he
won that award but seriously steam deck
is incredible dang he didn't have to
call him out like that he did it Awards
watch 60 Minutes of the show tonight on
our twitch Channel and you'll get the
limited edition Jeff Keeley Among Us
masks October 31st gotcha here's award
costume in Fall guys come on Hogwarts
Legacy already right
fingers crossed we'll be right
back from Hozier and the
[Applause]
end all right Break Time Break Time
I'm gonna turn down the background music
a bit yeah
This Server were here for me yo everyone
so surprise so far the the
length of the
um the speech or just overall the games
that came out so far
[Music]
that's crazy chat what you got
dude I was telling my chat I really wish
Nintendo needs to hurry up and come out
with a new Switch
ing yes that thing is so underpowered at
this point
I yo I'm still shocked they were still
trying to do it on the switch
I think the max is like 720 like
resolution and then you got the OLED one
but like it's it's still just like
better colors and stuff yeah but it
still has the same insides like exactly
everything it's not that high powered at
all
oh my gosh what do you what do you think
is going on with the switch
they keep saying soon and I'm like okay
what is soon
I I would be surprised if we get it
before summer
um
all right like I would be very surprised
and I feel like most people aren't going
to be playing on switch but every time I
see you talking about it or I talk about
it there's always a couple people in
chat who are saying oh I'm so
disappointed that's what I I'm playing
it on a lot of people because the thing
is not a lot of people are hardcore
Gamers right especially expect oh shoot
especially
um Wizarding World fans yo
wait is this a new
I don't know what this is
kalista it's kalista oh okay yeah it's
Calista yeah it's like surely they
wouldn't show no no Norman Reedus I was
thinking it was the death stranding yeah
yeah
I was like there's no way they're
showing new games like as an ad or
something for sure I'm still just
shocked that they even announced a
switch version it just seemed to come
out of nowhere
I mean it wasn't on the website before
um the game the state of play right then
after the state of play it they
announced it's going to be on the switch
so I'm just like
and they didn't even announce it as part
of the event it was just kind of after
oh here's the switch logo yeah yep yep
yep on the website and on at the end of
the thing but granted I mean this is it
was during a PlayStation state of play
true I guess they couldn't elaborate on
it but still that that took a lot of
people by surprise
rise of the ghost Lord oh I agree Casey
says Nintendo needs to bring the
GameCube games I loved the GameCube yo
so underrated I know everybody talks
about N64 but GameCube man oh it's one
of my favorite sister I had so much fun
with that system yeah me too
I'm gonna refresh guys to make sure
[Applause]
all right we'll listen for a bit see if
it's good
nothing
major
Spyro and GameCube
they want everyone to have the game in
their hands literally I think I really
do think that's what it is Ravenclaw
Tyrell I think they saw that
we need to try to get this on every
system possible
song's amazing oh let me turn it up then
oh dude look at that I love the live
Orchestra
I hope there's no spoilers I haven't
played the game yet
Eternal Darkness
started Eternal Darkness I don't think I
ever beat it
no it was very highly acclaimed
all this is at the end of the game Katie
Johnny boy they banned you for saying my
language is passionate like Pacino
oh I have no idea what happened over
there we do keep it a family-friendly
stream here but
so you know PG
PG is is all good
little PG-13 every now and then
dude what is that instrument
[Music]
I know go see ghosts here's what
happened
I literally have the
at the collector's edition
but I was like I want to replay 2018
before I play
Ragnarok
and so I started it like a week before
so I was like I'm just gonna play
through the story but I got so into
doing all the stuff
I'm like I want to get the platinum
trophy so I've been just like taking my
time doing the side quests getting um
beating all the Valkyries I just
finished off all the Valkyries now I'm
trying to get all the other little stuff
but I have it I have it ready to go
as soon as I get the Platinum it got a
war I'm moving I'm moving on to it
been blue
[Music]
oh
that that main theme right there of God
of War is so good
that's understandable
thank you thank you I'm glad I'm glad
you could understand it's the Trophy
Hunter in me
who is this thing good question if I was
Liz I should have been listening I'm
sure they said it there you go Nico yes
thank you
[Music]
we'll see I'd already played 2018 Ryan I
just wanted to replay it and then it's
not I know the story but then I just
wanted to go and get everything
spoilers are gonna cry now
[Music]
nice that was good
men never cry
I don't cry often but what an incredible
performance they're they're every now
and then air times sincerely a joy to
hear the music from games we love come
to life yes we do right amazing what
that Orchard puts together in just a few
weeks Ryan fair enough I cried at the
end of it to pay tribute to our game of
the year nominees
this year a record-setting number of you
voted 55 million for the game awards on
our website on Billy Billy in China and
on our Discord server you can head over
to Discord no way they're going to tell
them tonight game Award winner right now
right now to present our next award from
the new film Glass Onion that Knives Out
mystery premiering December 23rd on
Netflix please welcome Jessica hennick
most anticipated
come on
[Applause]
I don't want to alarm anyone
but someone in this room
is a murderer
foreign
[Applause]
we're just joking around but
I'm sorry okay
it's not a very pleasant thought
cried during Overture right Music Man
music is powerful star of Glass Onion
Daniel Craig
oh this is for the uh
Knives Out thing hello Game Awards
film we have a special scene Daniel just
starts talking and he just started
laughing what the hell something to that
that's you that's been Wildlife oh my
gosh that's why I was laughing I think
very nice yeah yeah and now
Best debut finding it hard to believe
we're in heaven
Norco
[Applause]
oh that's gonna win
my money's on stray for this one yeah I
don't even need to see the rest yeah
yeah
straight to the World by storm
down below the seven yep
didn't feel like they had that many
for Best debut India yeah I mean most of
them has been like five right four or
five yep stray yep
I put a poll on YouTube and said asking
people's game of the year and there were
quite a few that said stray
I heard that too
I heard that too
all right let's see how long this speech
goes
it's gonna be short as crap I bet it is
too
it's gonna be so short thank you so much
it's an incredible Honor on behalf of
the whole team in Montpellier is
probably watching right now hi guys
I want to thank everyone that was
involved in making this uh this game
it's really a work of love and passion
and all the talented members of our team
put everything they have to a few
instruments give you the feels like the
cello thanks to everyone who has helped
us along the way our friends family I
had a friend in college that played
played cello obviously
pretty important original kid Hogwarts I
guess he's winning we'll see we'll see
amazing
I need to play straight I'm like live
stream that actually it's just a short
game that'd be a fun one to stream isn't
just like a couple of hours
do like a two three hour stream one
night try to get through it people enjoy
it and react to it is the best feeling
in the world so we need more steel decks
right
[Applause]
all right you nailed it James
an exclusive first look at the gameplay
from lightfall Destiny next chapter
launching in February I used to be a big
fan of Destiny powers of the universe
and cancel the apocalypse
I used to play so much Destiny chat the
first one I played a ton and the second
one I played a lot in the beginning and
then just
fell out of it man now I'm so far behind
I don't think I could get back in
The
Impossible I believe straight I think
Strays on PC as well isn't straight on
everything
well not switch I don't think but
I know it's on PS PlayStation for sure
because I saw it on the uh
PlayStation Plus
Lauren we don't even know for sure if
it's gonna be there we might go through
this whole night with nothing on
Hogwarts Legacy
might go through with nothing
stray because I love the story
The Blob eyes you couldn't destroy
oh yeah I haven't played so I don't know
it's on the switch too okay nice
now somebody said stray is a PS
exclusive what
all right all right chat you're giving
me mixed signals here
yo volte with the Super Chat
what is up volte welcome thank you so
much for the support hi I'm here now who
won so far also hope everyone is having
a good night uh let's see if we can
remember multi versus one best fighting
game
we had
[Applause]
um Christopher Judge won best actor for
God of War we had what else did we hit
dang it dude I saw the WB wait
Rocksteady
yeah yeah
no
all right because it's just Gotham nice
no they're not doing it no this this is
um this suicide suicide suicide yeah
Suicide Squad
that's why I think the lady I forgot
about that it's coming out next year oh
it wasn't Batman darn it they did that
on purpose they did
you're supposed to be dead right in this
game or no that's Gotham Knights that's
Gotham Knights I don't know what's going
on here I know the Justice League is
like taken over by something
it's like suicide squad kill the Justice
League that's right
all right I'm gonna be quiet so I can
hear him okay
this looks good
oh
wait why can't he run away
what am I missing guys
Batman is dead in this timeline Batman
faked his death in Arkham Knight
still using Shadows
don't sweat it Batman doesn't kill
people
uh oh so who is it
yo
dude did he have like oh I don't think
that's him
he's got like purple eyes or something
what the heck vengeance
I am the Knight
I am
back oh man yeah
shout out to Kevin Conroy
[Applause]
after 30 years is the iconic voice of
Batman in the Arkham video game all
right so the Stray question Google says
PS5 PS4 Microsoft Windows passed away
last month there you go guys he was such
an iconic voice he was so amazing in the
Arkham games and I know we're all gonna
miss him dearly well tonight we can
share that he will return to
rocksteady's Arkham verse one final time
to play Batman in Suicide Squad who
killed the Justice League when the game
releases on May 26th of next year
that's cool
so I guess that would be his uh guys we
think about the next phase of our
industry it might be his last game
unless he had recorded something else
that's why we have our game awards
future class presented by Old Spice and
tonight over 75 members of the class
from the past two years are here in the
audience hello guys
and this week hey future class that's
getting a little closer 50 new members
you can read about them at
tgafutureclass.com and right now meet
one of this year's new members a chemist
turn Game Dev at intersloth who also
happens to be a street dancer
yeah guys careful with the spoilers
Among Us and I'm it's all good you can't
avoid spoiling everything but I was
looking at the movement of NP
and realize that
body control the robotics we have all
right James future like that's getting
closer to anticipated
really yeah right we're inching closer
I feel like that's the easy transition
yep it's an easy transition all right
Chad here we go
okay now it's like commercials yeah some
more now I've been told in my chat that
twitch is like way ahead if we want to
watch it on Twitch all right I'm I'm
cool with that all right so because I
think this is a break right here I just
gotta sign in
I got to do some technical stuff
uh switch it over let's see here let me
see if we can do that
oh
you guys can stay right here you don't
have to leave yeah we're not going
anywhere just adding a little wrinkle to
some stuff
but yeah chat what has been the game for
you so far that you you probably will
play relaxing Animal Crossing like
experience Animal Crossing like
experience
team will improve your relationship with
friends oh brother they got the game
awards on the front and center the party
animals
the battle of the most epic animal
characters story yeah Wolfie we don't
even know we don't even know for sure if
it's gonna be here
we do not know for sure however
I just feel like they're gonna show
something actual Royal Corgi I mean like
Chandler and Eric and they they could go
out there just just to have fun hang out
have a good time actual but part of me
feels like
they're there because they're I don't
know dude we're probably just over
analyzing like we always do but
I'm still gonna say join the epic battle
that we that we're gonna see something
don't try these forgot your Twitch
password yeah you guys can stay right
here on YouTube destroying the world and
I'll just pull it up right here
make sure that yeah that's that's
showing up just right [ __ ] black hole
Al Pacino was the highlight
yeah man that's why like I haven't
watched a lot of these in years because
I feel like there's a lot of these
moments you know
but we all know so James have you
watched do you normally watch the game
awards
yeah I watched the past uh two well I've
watched it past three and uh stream the
last two oh nice see I watched like one
of the I don't know the first two or so
they did and then I just got to the
point where I felt like it was so much
time for so a little yeah that you
really get every award show is like that
that's why when chat was asking if I was
gonna live stream it I was like maybe
but then when I thought
I thought there's a pretty good chance
we'll see something with Hogwarts Legacy
but then when I asked you as like dude
let's co-stream it and when you said you
were on board I was like okay then
that'll make it go by faster having
somebody to talk to and chat with in
between yeah all the filler stuff I
spend more time with chat than I do the
actual uh stream so yeah from HBO will
be with us to present an award
to present best adaptation please
welcome the most best adaptation
pay it
you just found out the game Hearts
exists this year
I mean they've always had like ever
since I can remember they've had some
kind of end of year Video Game Awards
but Jeff Keeley the main host there
he did he started gosh I don't know five
six years ago now really trying to make
it like a
Hollywood type production like like this
and it's really come a long way really
come a long way
compared to what it used to be
and like G4 did some stuff back in the
day
oh based off the games
the cuphead show I didn't know that was
his name I didn't either
oh there it is
my kids loved the first one I haven't
seen the second one the easy second one
is good it's better
I think it's on it might be on Netflix
now and
Charlie doesn't get in Uncharted wasn't
that good
there you go I think Arcane is on
Netflix I believe it is I have it on my
watch list
along with like 200.
wow
I mean it's incredible honor to you know
be awarded by yeah you got any snacks
tonight James oh I got Welsh's fruit
snacks
journey of getting here hey don't make
too much noise while I was snacking on
them so I'm like we're good I know right
it's hard to snack on stream yeah like
Go mute or something yeah um and I got
some orange juice what about you of
course Riot I finished my black cherry
Waterloo oh nice I got nothing it's been
incredible let's say you're glad they're
refreshing doing another commercial
break for sure yeah Gabe we switched
over to uh twitch because the
some people had James's chat were saying
it's a little bit ahead
later we'll have the first clip from the
new Super Mario Brothers animated movie
yeah I think that looks so good I just
go back to the games coming later I love
the style yeah
a new look at cyberpunk's Phantom
Liberty expansion come on just say it
Jeff gameplay
lots more steam decks to give away but
now it's time for the world premiere of
a long-awaited game long awaited oh it's
not World premiere though oh no no it
wouldn't it wouldn't be World premiere
dang it
3 A.M whoa it was three you guys go to
sleep it's three a.m oh my gosh
what is this
dude it looks like Eddie Munson from
stranger things in there yo the hair yes
and there's no shirt oh my gosh it's
true
stranger things game confirmed he's like
getting revived in the upside down
is gone
he's gone yo
here we go this is the Fallen order or
um the next one
let's go
I'm ashamed to say I need to play the
first one
I did do that one
oh that is awesome
got some um hypocrite action right here
yeah
yeah reminder friend here
yo Noob with another Super Chat did I
just hear you don't have hydration I
feel betrayed I drank it all wait hold
on there is like a drop there's a drop
now it's totally gone totally gone
that's it
might have to run and grab something
here in a bit let's see what time is it
okay we're almost an hour in
I feel like we got another hour to go
an hour possibly a little bit more
oh yeah I know I'd love it if I played
it
as long as we fight
[Music]
hope survives
March did they say
that's right after Hogwarts guys
right after Hogwarts
March 17th
yeses so March 17th right after Hogwarts
too so say it it only they only have oh
this is the actor Star Wars
Monahan yo he killed it as a Joker in
Gotham too
oh he played him too yeah he played
Joker um in Gotham it's an incredible
honor to wield this lightsaber again
he looks I think I can speak for
everybody the motion Cat when they it
looks just like him you look dislike I'm
really excited we are to show our work
on Jedi Survivor
I had the chance to play the game
recently and I can honestly say dude you
guys can hear the best Star Wars games
of all time you can hear like the
yeah I have no doubt that you're the
lightsaber in the background
I'm
so incredibly lucky to be a part of this
incredible project and it's really
something extraordinary so
we'll see you all in a galaxy far far
away March 17th and until then
May the force be with you dude I gotta
play the first one
I gotta play the first one
Go Happy Birthday to me it's incredible
I can't wait to play Jedi and I gotta
play the first one yes so I can get
ready for it next we're proud to support
independent games here at the game
awards yeah
between those two yeah
what we got here World premiere that's
not us right
right yeah it's a different game
I guess it could be a World premiere
trailer but if he says like First Look
it's not yeah first yeah yeah
did you place the list
these are coming back these type of
games I heard Celeste was really good
more narrative than anything
goon Hogwarts likes he's the only one I
want
comes out one year oh Star Wars J Rossi
one year from the state of play
yeah it's one of those I know I would
love it man I know I would love it if I
played it
the Star Wars Jedi game
in a big pass
yeah this is not really my kind of game
either
but if it's anything like Celeste I know
there will be a lot of people who like
it
Celeste was so good Nico said
uh we don't know for sure mythical gamer
in years past they've been three hours
and Jeff Keeley said it's going to be
significantly shorter this year so my
guess has been around two hours which
would be
I mean we have about another hour to go
but it wouldn't be shocking if they ran
over because they've already had one of
the speeches went particularly long but
there might be other areas where they
can make up time just have to see
that was interesting but not coming
until 2024.
I have a dream
pre-alpha footage okay so this is you
this game's a ways out
volte with another Super Chat they
should be showing Hogwarts Legacy
because it would be a great way to
advertise the game so more people would
buy I mean especially so close to launch
right the testing
like all of us the hardcore know about
it but this is a good chance to like get
a little bit more
mainstream you know
hype but you have so many questions
Timothy about the the Star Wars one
what is this right here
I have no idea
of these things in my dream sleeper
I am
terrified wait what of what happens when
you awaken Awakening
dude
dude I didn't know they were making a
oh wait I did hear about this the MMO
yeah they announced the last year I want
to say or at least during like Gamescom
or something
that was your first in-engine look at
Dune Awakening tonight all the major
gaming platforms are offering special
discounts and offers on special
discounts check out the game award sale
across steam Xbox PlayStation epic store
and special offers on nominees on the
Nintendo eShop and that's not all in
celebration of TGA you can also play
free demos of many upcoming games across
steam Xbox and for the first time
PlayStation and right now we're excited
to share news about a place
tonight on PlayStation
true
the playable demo
dude if they announce the playable demo
oh my gosh bruh
yo what happens if they announce that
tonight
dude yo I would lose my mind I know what
you and I would be doing tonight yo we
would immediately start streaming
exactly
exactly
hey Jim and bread it's 4 a.m go to bed
oh my gosh you guys thanks for the
support but gracious I don't want to
miss that your help
and see when he said PlayStation it was
like oh they do have a marketing thing
with this that's what I'm saying I'm
saying the first time plays Dean
it's kind of cool whatever this is yeah
this uh a lot of people have been
waiting for this game end this once and
for all I think we're supposed to get
gameplay this first spoken yeah I think
we're supposed to get a game play
tomorrow
because this got delayed too available
now yeah yeah I might check it out
it looks amazing I think Andy did some
videos on that yeah and Alex yep yep
commercial time yeah I know top up on
all your drinks and snacks everybody we
got another commercial hey yeah yep
commercial time they gotta pay for the
game awards yeah
yo hey yo yeah you got to play Jedi
um I do I really do yeah I'm like you my
backlog is just so so bad it's so bad
which if I could make a commitment to
really get back into streaming again
like I used to I could start knocking
them out yeah yeah yeah have people
watch along with me yeah don't worry
about
um trying to get platinum or anything
just playing through I know I'm just
such a sucker for the like trophies yeah
we all are the completion to say this
all yo Alicia with a super chat got you
here with Noob on call too
yo
yo that's that's not a bad idea playing
some games on Twitch I need to get my
streaming muscles back up with gaming
too so yeah everybody keeps asking me
all right so
let's say we okay first let's say we do
get Hogwarts Legacy early I hope we do
then once the game goes live for
everybody would you be streaming it live
see that's what I was telling my chat I
was like if we get it early I feel like
I definitely would but if we don't get
it early I don't know if I would want my
first playthrough to be
I might just like record it instead of
live streaming it yeah
you're porn though because I I that
first time I really just want to be
immersed right yeah right yeah that's
that's that's the hard part now I don't
mind crying on screen because I probably
will cry when I first might be able to
play it but like yo yeah I'm with you on
that because I'm just like man just
recorded and then like do some tips or
whatever like things I wish I knew when
I started the game or something but like
I I don't know man I'm still torn and we
got like two months left
so yeah
because I just want to immerse it like I
don't want to the YouTube or content
creator to get in the way I know right
just being a first play this game yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah everybody say we got
a live stream there oh my gosh
so and they also you got to worry about
spoilers too because not everybody will
get it whether we get it early before
the 7th or on the 7th of February so not
everybody will have it they might want
to keep away spoilers and stuff so
that was the other thing I was asking my
chat I was like would you guys even
watch us live streaming it because
aren't you all gonna be playing exactly
I was like the first couple days like
our view and attendance would drop
drastically the first couple of days
exactly
an upcoming characters
next is something truly truly special
tonight all of us together would be
truly special experience the global
announcement of the next game from one
of our industry's most Visionary game
studios Okay I'm intrigued please enjoy
what is this I don't know I'm intrigued
captured on PS5
[Music]
what in the world
Sony interactive entertainment
oh this is uh
oh
it's the it's dead stranding
yo
I didn't play the first one
[Music]
did you guys like it was it good
I heard it's like real Hit or Miss like
some people just
love it
and some people are like no
no
I'm loving this music though
close your
tired and I'll wait
and soon
I'll see your smile
smile energy
I guess this is kind of a spoiler for
the first game
since there is a baby now
I thought it was a hiking simulator
I know Jay Rossi right
is it horror though Timothy
I didn't think it was horror
be wrong
[Applause]
[Music]
well that was depressing
no
I feel like you need to have played the
first one to understand this I do not
know what's happening right now
wow
wow there it is
I know nothing about it
dude oh my gosh it's still going I meant
it when I said I understand how you feel
oh my gosh Norman
oh my God
did you play the first one James no yeah
me neither I have no idea what's going
on
so you tried it it wasn't for you yeah
yeah it was too slow for me
I don't have time
I I need to play it though
yeah I've heard it's very Hit or Miss
like you either just totally love it or
yeah
another metal gear solid or a remake or
something man please
decision
that's a big announcement though right
there yeah
for sure
[Music]
it's not creepy at all what
[Music]
what
we have connected
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
he's a legend but God there she is yeah
that's the actress
uh nothing yet nothing personal nothing
yet they haven't even done the most
anticipated you're on this stage with us
in 2019 where you won best game
Direction uh DS2 has been announced uh
what can you tell us how is it going to
be different than DS1
[Music]
dude look at his jacket
I can't really be specific right now but
you just seen the trailer and I put a
lot of things inside so I want you guys
to talk about it and find Details In It
Secrets good luck all right secrets we
have some of the cast from the game with
us here uh hello Liz Shelley great to
have you guys with us here
um Troy is here as well we heard him
there hello Troy
um we're so excited about this
collaboration you have with an amazing
cast I wanted to ask you the story of
this game how is the pandemic and what
we've been through how is that oh that'd
be nice Brendan if they did that tonight
I don't feel like it would be the place
for it but they they keep saying soon so
you never know I had the story written
before the pandemic but after experiment
experiencing the pandemic I just rewrote
the whole thing uh the story from
scratch wow
I also didn't want to predict any more
future so I rewrote it
[Applause]
it's always such a pleasure having you
here I wanted something in the first
game must have been you as a Creator a
little too on the nose podcast
he basically said kick rocks right he's
like you saw the trailer that's all I'm
telling you
soon
right now and also one other title
that's completely new I'm kind of
experimenting at the moment and also
other visual projects I'm still working
on so I'll hope to reveal it soon I said
well you're always there are other
visual projects like a movie or
something Dale Kojima everyone
thank you so much Rocky thank you
thank you well next we have another
Global game announcement we're proud to
announce a new game for any new world
ascendant Studios a team with experience
making story-driven FPS games like Dead
Space Halo and Bioshock they partnered
with EA Originals labeled label behind
last year's Game of the Year winner
anyone checking Chandler's Twitter well
he's at the event
a regional World here is your first
Glimpse and one reason that I think we
may not get anything which I've already
predicted I said I think we will but
one reason we may not is I usually feel
like Chandler's pretty forthcoming
beforehand
a great menu but then then they'd like
to throw curveballs too so
nope nothing so far Neil
I think so far
let me look at Chandler's Twitter right
now
oh so you did tweet one hour ago honor
to be attending the game awards for
representing Avalanche WB feels like a
huge career Milestone and a perfect one
to land right near my one year
anniversary with the studio
oh he's there with the uh the lady from
James's behind the scenes video
remember her name but
the last James here in a second
Immortals of
avium
noobs membership ran out what noobs
always gifted memberships too
now he's an actor who recently performed
in midnight mass and Ghostbusters
Spirits Unleashed please welcome Rahul
Kohli
as an actor I'm drawn to Old stories but
I think that's true of all of us
especially those who pick up a
controller narrative engagement story
slippery thing because there's no single
way to tell a story
even happen in that order and for each
other and retro are the same person what
but to be truly invested I think
Chandler and I look anything like
Chandler doesn't have a beard that's
another life first of all these are the
nominees for best narrative best
narrative okay okay best narrative
was always worried that it would start
all over again I've heard that it's
really good
golden ring for best narrative yeah God
of War 2 there yeah yeah
this is not the first time to be going
against each other
my money's on God of War but I wouldn't
be shocked if that a plague tale Requiem
won
and the game Award for best narrative
ghost too I'm just I'm just gonna say
Ragnarok God of War Ragnarok yeah
yeah narrative yeah that's that game was
all a narrative
that's what that's what has me so
excited about August Lacey the real
story driving everything like
I know it's open world and stuff but
like it's very story driven so
yeah
did you see Chandler's tweet from an
hour ago
uh which one
just the one about them being being
there and there are he had a couple
pictures with one of the ladies who was
in here behind the scenes I couldn't
remember her name yes
um I forgot her name um in a video game
that's going to kill me she was there
and then there was one other person he
was with so yeah I didn't I didn't
recognize the other guy because that's
not Andrew artists
it didn't look like Mercer or any of the
other people I met music so it might be
somebody he knows chat was telling me to
check his tweets and look for Clues
um they elevate everything they look
like they're just having a good time it
does yeah I'm honored to accept this on
their behalf
um I want to thank uh Playstation uh
Scott so the longer we go we feel like
yeah you feel like there's a better
chance
I know me too it's always like this it's
where it's a game that's already
announced they've already showed a lot
it wouldn't be like an in the show kind
of trailer I don't think no no no
so like I'm just uh I'm great they may
have they might have like put all their
ducks in a row for ccxp and then like
the next footage would be like a
gameplay showcase or something yeah yeah
Sue's gameplay showcase right or
whatever
Corey
quote unquote out of town
Rich tonight
Corey step aside for me yes I I hope
they do another one for sure I think
it'd be supportive and a lot of fun yeah
I I I still think it will be because
what they did at the end of Mines like
they showed like Channel even said like
what possibly you know teasing showing
like outside the castle
exactly exactly so I hope that's a
burden I wouldn't wish I hope we get
that whether it's this month or the
beginning of uh the year kind of
starting that off right psycho thank you
for the Super Chat I think I think Elder
ring will win game of the year I do
it'll definitely win something but the
best narrative let's go I feel like that
one's probably gone
so it just made sense to show you the
first time who's with the kids right
play of Tekken eight oh here you go back
in yeah
I used to love tekkens legendary
fighting franchise
I just want to see how how much
different it looks right how's it
changed
whatever
oh that's gin
oh you know the people I don't know
anybody oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
that long yo
I mean I think this looks more fun than
Street Fighter that they should I agree
it looks way better being somebody who
doesn't care you know
this one's way better
oh cool
oh it's not backwards compatibility
yeah more Awards and winners here are
the nominees for best art Direction
maybe he's going to do like a couple
yeah
straight Elder ring and the game award
goes to yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's easy
here are the nominees for best VR come
on come on
phone lab I have no idea
Moss book
Mario and rabbits Sparks of Hope Total
War
I'll say totally just because I'll say
total war
that's a good guess too
Mario now
I got it I got it that's good
how did he support presented by Discord
oh Destiny 2.
[Music]
that's so oh my gosh that's a strong
role game I'll just say destiny 2.
Tennessee 14. wow wow I was gonna guess
fortnite check out their Discord
Community yeah I know a lot of people
still play much more games yes
here's a new look at Nightingale a first
person PVE open world survival crafting
game that we first announced last year
right here it's like such a long
description no First World open world or
first person open world something
yeah
hey somebody just stepped in I gotta get
her on a headset oh
yeah we got Sue here
I need to see you emotes in the chat
hold on retro let me get a link yeah
yeah you're good
the magical network of portals has
collapsed Nightingale yeah I don't know
about this normal people Acosta beyond
the Frontiers
uh Sue it's your first time reading
retro live with monsters Sue hello how's
it going I told James I was a little
nervous about virtually meeting you ever
since I saw the clip of uh you know that
that whole Mary kiss kill situation
it's like I don't want it to be weird
between a suit it doesn't happen
oh I got such a good laugh out of that
somebody in my Discord sent me the exact
link to it exact time
[Music]
I've forgot that it happened actually
[Laughter]
yeah well you said it I was like oh my
gosh that's right like I was so weird
like I was just like I can't believe
they asked me that well I was watching
at that stream and I just somehow missed
that I don't know
and then sue at the end said retro did
you hear James he's gonna marry you I
was like what what are you talking about
okay we never talk about this so Chad is
that this does not leave chat ever again
don't pick it up again
oh man yeah that was so funny because he
took a lot of time to really think
through his hand tonight
everybody in here is member of the
unspeakables do not talk about the Xbox
series
Jonas on Instagram at average underscore
Jonas for more fun details yet I was
gonna say sue you haven't missed much at
all yet no big Awards yet
okay it's been not a good time yeah
we've gotten like one couple of good
games a couple of like hey we'll play it
or whatever but a lot of passes
according to you yo what's up Dylan yeah
so what were the most exciting ones far
for me Jedi Survivor we'll be with the
Super Chat getting laid over here I'll
have to head off thanks for the stream
retro same boat we get Legacy
uh what was that
most exciting game so far so far ah
probably the Star Wars yeah
yeah that one looks really good
out of it honestly sometimes I need to
play the first one though we were
talking about I missed that yeah yeah we
still got a lot of people saying hi hi
everybody
it's a big second commitment yeah for
sure I got you a few more codes for
different things you would like yeah
we'll be um I'm gonna share a couple of
codes with retro he's just finding out
about this now wait we gotta and we got
a couple of game codes given from some
of the cats in the community as they say
we can give away so we'll do it all in
Discord so be sure to join expect a
ghost Discord and of course retro record
towards Discord go to his uh Channel and
he'll have them Linked In His
description of this video so go check
them out and uh we'll coordinate
something tonight or tomorrow so thanks
Dr Strange again for the codes
yeah thank you Doctor Strange
[Laughter]
masters of Mystic cards
oh my gosh Cindy four months a member
Sam welcome to the party suit
happy to be here yeah she's just popping
in
um
stressful events I thought it was well
they did say it was going to be shorter
this year I think Jeff said
significantly shorter but so yeah he
said 2.5 hours
to talk to someone 10 30. you don't have
a support system we're not including the
prefer and and the long speech yeah
exactly exactly yeah it was a long
speech really the very first one yeah
ingredients
it was like literally over seven minutes
I'm not even joking the God of War actor
I mean it was a good speech but yeah he
did go on
yeah I was surprised they didn't play
the music earlier obviously the best
yeah seven minutes is too many minutes
we're talking that's a long time yeah
um
with the three months oh my gosh thank
you thank you
thank you
you acting like she doesn't have an NDA
not to talk about the new challenges are
absolute Legends very first game oh yes
showcase is that what they're talking
about yeah
I'm not even fighting it because I'm
like if there's anything I say
right
and it launches January 19th everyone
please join me and welcoming to the game
awards Ken and Roberta Williams
I don't recognize the names neither do I
oh then
[Laughter]
I don't know who these are
thanks to the super chat again Dustin
many many years ago we knew the
potential was there oh we should
probably know who they are
even to change the world
we're honored to be back here to present
the award for games for impact which
recognizes
Lee what Enfield what does that even
mean in these clothes in a black shirt
games for impact
games for impact okay
Pokemon violence guard are let Downs
yeah I heard they uh don't run too well
cycle you take your chances wake up
sleeper Jake what's up yes I will I will
let James know he's streaming live too
he could pop in and say hi on you could
do the uh
you can get the dual monitors going if
you need to
and the game award for games for impact
goes to
I'm kind of surprised we haven't gotten
dusk Falls
[Applause]
it's a great category a great Chris it's
a great category I just wish I knew I
wish I knew more about wines and why
they were in this category yeah the
impact they had
if they love your confused faces thank
you yeah I didn't know I was telling
James earlier Sue like since I started
doing so many videos my actual game
playing time has just plummeted thank
you so much I haven't played a lot of
these
so
yeah I um I hit Max rank in Wizards
United it was like level 60 you and
James James was still Level like 30 31
32. goodness because he spent all his
time making content
actually playing the game yeah yeah
that's how it goes that is the dangerous
this is not
multiple yes so is it still like can you
play Wizards unite at all now or is the
game just totally it's just it
represents it's still on my phone but
nothing happens
it comes up with like a screen that says
goodbye basically and oh my goodness
yeah I still have it on my phone though
too and we hope I would never delete
that thing uh see that's what like
process that's one of the sad parts
about how like the direction games are
going it's like so many of them have
such important online components and you
can't just go back and play it like
games from back in the day yeah
of you it's crazy man and the thing is
like so many like especially don't have
a long lifespan anymore radically mobile
you know and so like it's like yo you
either hit or we want to move on to the
next thing and their community that was
built on the game that still wants to
play it you're like it's the bottom line
it's the bottom dollar so yeah this is
unite forever but yeah it's one of those
things where
[Applause]
um
they started her music way too quick yo
I'm telling you they're trying to fly
through this thing all the other
people's time now the team at larion is
ready to share just when you're going to
be able to join the party
Sue earlier they had a game where they
released a demo like right now yeah yeah
and James and I said imagine if they if
they dropped to Hogwarts Legacy demo how
much we would lose it
it would take a minute for me to
actually realize like
I just don't do what right now yeah I
know Sue would sue would be like James
here's the PS4 I'm gonna hop on the PS5
and download this demo
bags
rightfully so yes
that was one of my favorite moments and
you're all stream it's just her reaction
James just casually drops you'll play on
the PS4 I'll be on the PS5 she's like
wait what what did you say
okay no we did talk about it after he
was just envisioning us both wanting to
play simultaneously okay yeah yeah and
we don't have two PS5 so
for all of those times where we both are
going to be playing video games at the
same time and I was just like James said
it never happened it's not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen
so yeah that was that was a breaking
case of emergency type yeah yeah
assumption right there just in case so
you're still keeping your PS4 copy James
oh yeah yeah yeah
it's just in case of emotions
this case both of us are up at 2 am
playing the game
yeah look you have to keep it this is
Dragon Age oh my goodness uh Baldur's
Gate something oh bald is gay okay
yo the eye on the chest reminds me of
Hogwarts Legacy
dude
yeah I might have to check this out
because you do DND here with Joe MADD
Legends
CEO of Airship syndicated
I want Hogwarts to win just so we can
hear Chandler give a speech up there yes
they're there yeah Chandler Eric
success over the last 10 years and now
we're going to leverage uh their
expertise on our new game uh which is a
character based on top of the Hogwarts
like we just don't eat us fantasy world
and we're super excited and uh I think
there's a little bit more you got
another partner to talk about too we do
another partner uh has come on board uh
to support us and James I'm muting
periodically if you like if I don't know
for a second no you're good you're good
I'm talking to chat and you like all at
the same time because I know yeah here
we go I know thanks
foreign
World premiere
PlayStation
it's a rival brought chaos
Dragon Age Dreadful
I mean this looks like a
looks like a game I would like wait is
this Warcraft no it looks like it though
we Face the danger like the art style
troll the chaos are they gonna make us
wait to the end mythical gamer sadly we
don't even know if it's gonna be here
for sure
like the longer we go honestly I'm I'm
getting worried
getting concerned
but yeah elwin I don't think Hogwarts
Legacy will have any mimic chests we
shall see
wayfinders hey Patty foot how's it going
welcome
Torchlight
I don't know but I'm I'm kind of digging
this actually whatever it is
it definitely looks like an MMO
something you could play with friends
Control the Chaos
wayfinder okay steam PS5 PS4
play it next week
[Applause]
looks interesting
come in so many passes another place
we got a lot of passes on the previous
game
a lot of people saying pass yeah so many
passes yeah yeah
you ever played any MMOs yes I love Fire
Emblem
yeah yeah
I guess the closest I've ever like
Destiny is you know kind of an MMO yeah
yeah
I got really into that don't hold this
against me Destiny man there's a lot of
people still play I was talking to
Chandler and he's like yo he's he's
still playing I don't even know if he
still does but like he he was heavy into
um there's a lot of passes on fire
bro I'm telling you there's only been
like one wherever I was like volte with
a super chill that's the Star Wars game
and then the anticipation is killing me
yeah and we don't even know
we don't know for sure company creators
of Journey and sky and singer-songwriter
Aurora welcome to the game award I
thought we would have for sure gotten
the most anticipated award fairly early
so they might save it for the later when
when they get close you know kind of
like hey here are the games you might
see as game of the year next year oh
it's like the last thing yeah
yes so tell us this is an amazing
collaboration
we think it will be there we know it's
nominated
mostly because all of the people that
are working on Skype how ironic we are
anticipating for the most anticipating
gay Awards right I mean this project is
so full of love it'd be cool if they won
but what I'd really like to see is a new
trailer or something that's what I'd
really like to see isn't that what I
said from yeah you got you guys have
from the start been saying it's gonna be
at the end yeah I I got to experience
thank you so much for the Super Chat I
think it's kind of the future where
virtual concerts should go Genova you've
always built games gotta Save The Best
For Last Apollo said I wouldn't Peg you
as someone that would go into the
virtual probably saving him for the very
end
I mean I don't think the game awards
would care how a game can make you feel
and with our games connect two people
but with that game company
they made Journey that game is so good
thousands of people about to announce a
delayed release date
don't say that I just played it with
don't say that this week and I don't
know what to say but so maybe we can
just look at a trailer that's what I'm
hoping Owen I hope we will see well we I
mean officially we haven't even seen the
Beast Mount trailer for uh flow flower
Journey for our territories like in good
quality we saw it thanks to some of our
Brazilian Hogwarts Legacy creators
because they were able to genuine humans
post footage of being Indian players in
the world at the event like a concert
you guys have ever played journey man
journey is so good very short
play that game alone play it with
headphones you connect with the artist
in the dark you can beat it in one
sitting it's so good we haven't felt
this in any video games
and after 18 months of experimentation
and development we feel it now
we made this concert completely free so
you can experience this amazing journey
with your friends and loved ones you can
download a concert that you can download
interesting food to concert join us for
this groundbreaking moment shared by
millions of players worldwide
check that out it's really really you
know what happens at the end you haven't
played it though
the game awards even if you know the
answer
pubg mobile you'll receive a free very
different type of game like it's not not
a lot of action we'll also be able to
participate in pubg Mobile and complete
other challenges terms and conditions
apply
Marshall break
all right commercial break currently on
the server the concert is packed
nice
cheese pumped about yeah
it's because they are called the game
company they already deserve my like
did you play a journey James no no did
you yeah it's one of my favorite games
ever it's so good really it's short too
I thought being a PlayStation guy you
might have came across it but it's
um
play it you know you can play it in one
sitting like that's how short it is
oh I love that yeah play it in a dark
room headphones just like get the full
experience
okay I think they brought it to they
might have brought it to PC
I think they did yeah I might have to
check that out
it's gonna say second place guy I've
heard this guy
because we have a Nintendo switch
channel and uh there's a lot of people
that actually play it
I got a lot of love for Journey in here
in the chat over here
so people are agreeing with you nice
uh Jake and my chat ask if I will play
Star field
I think I would wait but almost
certainly at some point yeah yeah have
to
that's that's the undertaking though
right you got to set aside some time to
do that one that I think that's gonna
win most anticipated
is my you think so yeah
because of that remember that
description your chat was showing you
like the description that they put for
the award yeah
and Michael that's not a true most
anticipated
yeah what is this what is this
I like the vibe
blood feels like my kind of place
[Applause]
it's the artist
s
okay I was about to say diablo
[Music]
Morgana
wait those look exactly like the statues
but it's figures is is this the mobile
game a reference or something
let's see
just kidding
I like that I think I like like one of
two songs from her that hurts
sounds right whatever I'm serious
we're gonna go first
I tried the one of the Diablo games with
some friends who were so into it and I
just I just couldn't get into it
no felt like a lot of button mashing a
lot of people enjoy it though but yeah
it wasn't my cup of tea either
it's super popular though yes it is
I haven't Jake is it good I've heard
it's pretty good I don't think it
Congress agency can be put back on delay
I don't think that's gonna happen
um
like the music pass on the game a lot of
passes oh we got a trailer
no
[Music]
do a Diablo like dungeon see I kind of I
like I like the idea of a Dungeon
Crawler but just something about
I don't just felt like a lot of mash in
the same button over and over but I love
like that grindy like leveling up I love
all that part of it
all right don't be quiet turn this up
we're just here for Hogwarts Legacy guys
I'm talking through most of the stuff
we don't even know if we're gonna get
anything Hogwarts Legacy related anyway
Diablo 4.
who knows I might try it again maybe
maybe the next one I'd be into
nope nothing Alex nothing not even the
most anticipated award yet
not even the most anticipated
weird thing for Hogwarts game lava
right where is this
this is the uh horcrux making process
right here
JK Rowling would never reveal how
horcrux has were made here we go
this is it
oh my gosh
yo
just a super long spear
no mythical gamer
like something recently
I saw their picture that they're all
there
yeah I saw I saw their pictures so I
know they're there
Lord of the Rings nah this is this is
something with Diablo
I have returned to hell
yeah there you go you guys called it
Diablo four
June 6 20 23.
wow Diablo 4 and Halsey are just yes
unless you guys are talking about the
picture that's all I'm seeing Diablo and
Halsey next year but wasn't that
incredible thank you so much and he
retweeted that Rush Hour
winners tonight in the category of best
sports racing game phenomenal maybe
maybe uh FIFA 23 NBA answer is about 23.
I'll say NBA
mostly world and the game award goes
yeah didn't get any love you got it wow
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2.
Multiverse I would say Multiverse it's
just Turtles I'm just gonna say that
because that game was so much fun
Nostalgia shredders would probably get
it I have no idea
Splatoon three wow what all right
a bit of a surprise
Modern Warfare Call of Duty oh oh yo
Ragnarok I'll take you out of War
and this game award goes to
[Applause]
um
Carl Jacobs
no brew and QT Cinderella I only know
three of these
things congratulations I know yeah yeah
he's been here are the nominees for most
and here we go oh
Final Fantasy 16.
Hogwarts Legacy Resident Evil 4. he
looked up
Legend of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
maybe a fan favorite but and the game
award goes to
The Legend of Zelda
yeah
now it's time I want to see World
premiere I want to see the fan poll I
really hope they released that yeah yeah
because that was all journalists right I
really want to see
oh Horizon whoa this is the DLC
not not surprised that Zelda one guy I
thought I thought Starfield might Edge
it out
but maybe they'll release the uh
I mean Zelda's gonna be awesome too I
can't lie right
maybe they will release the the poll
results because that's what I'd be
really curious to see
is what one
the fan pull
if you guys didn't know the fan voting
only accounted for 10 and then the other
90 was a like a a jury panel that they
put together
Hollywood
Horizon burning Shores I guess at this
point I should just wait and buy the
full whenever they put out the package
that has all of them
April 19th oh my gosh dude so we got
like Hogwarts Legacy February Star Wars
March according Shores we'll see and
then that's in April pursue a Sinister
threat in the Untamed Wilds of Los
Angeles no gameplay or anything
Hollywood sign looks pretty cool and now
please welcome yeah Apollo Last of Us
show coming to H the fan voting was only
10 yeah
[Applause]
man I hope this show I hope this is good
dude I hope this is good
the show it's HBO man yeah
I loved her in Game of Thrones gosh just
right just real quick I know that I told
you guys this backstage but just in
front of everybody else I want to let
you know
we've seen the show and
we just love you as Joel and Ellie thank
you
thanks fans big fans so you know we are
big fans of you two as well as Joel and
Ellie
[Applause]
should we do this all together just like
Joel and Ellie's just one and all let's
do it awkward okay
we're here they're making us too awkward
best action game
have action and these are the ones
this kicks ass
[Applause]
there's always awkward moments in these
things
Bayonetta three
that's that's Gotta Have a good shot of
winning
I don't think it'll be Call of Duty I
don't even know what this is
foreign
a lot of good things about
I'm still my money's still on Bayonetta
oh my kids and I played this and loved
it I don't think it'll win but I love
that it's nominated I have fun with it
yeah I thought so
I thought so
I've never played any bayonettas neither
have I
chat is telling us to check Twitter to
see if they offer any uh um condolences
speeches
that's pretty awesome
um on behalf of the development teams at
Platinum Games
and Nintendo that worked tirelessly on
bringing Bayonetta to life for the third
time thank you so very much it's about
noon back in Japan tomorrow and I'm sure
they're watching right another from Eric
just for you folks congratulations
Chandler
no I think you all know this but no one
does
action games and over-the-top action
games like Platinum Games and as you saw
they're already hard at work that's a
switch exclusive right so they asked me
to say a few words on their behalf
with our long history of creating action
games it's a huge honor to be aware yeah
that's it in terms of what they could
win to reveal a brand new title for the
game awards today we'd like to thank
everyone who helped reveal a new title
Bayonetta title the fans of the series
with the characters just as important as
the many players uh as the many to the
many players is gameplay we hope you'll
keep your eyes peeled they are starting
the music next week
on everybody their names thank you very
much thank you
[Applause]
bro they are not easy they are not
playing around with the music anymore
they have a trio of exciting new game
announcements first let's head to Japan
for a special Rio of new game
announcements Japan okay
bloodborne 2 police I want a bloodborne
too so bad Namco
sounds like something new though
uh Richard I think we'll be there for
multiple years and meet Albus I don't
think so Zach I think it's gonna be one
year with with the hope and possibility
of sequels that take us through year six
and seven
um how disappointing uh it's I mean
little picket it's it was up against
really tough competition
and if you were if you didn't hear the
part where the fan voting actually only
only accounted for ten percent so the
other 90 was for the um the panel it's
like a jury panel which that jury panel
also nominated Hogwarts Legacy so to
even be in that category was
a pretty good side pretty good sign
all right what'd they call this blue
protocol or something
what our world was before
foreign
style before the Sun during
before the war
before the darkness
do you remember
you
Willborn 2 would be great
vati video showcase mini fan concepts
for what they want there's some great
options he had a poll he did a Twitter
poll today too that was like what would
you most want to see
from
from them
and bloodborne 2 was just barely edging
out
um Elder ring DLC which I I feel like
Elder ring DLC is almost a lock
to be here
but bloodborne 2 would be
amazing
well yeah the weirdest part Zach is like
if you went and read what the panel sure
on the website they had a description of
what
like what they're looking for the
criteria for most anticipated game and
it said something of like to the effect
of a game we talked about it last week
on the wait was it last week it was like
a couple weeks ago on stream we talked
about it had a line saying that the game
that will like push the industry forward
or something
and so that actually made me think star
field was probably gonna win because
it's trying to do a little bit more new
whereas um
tears of the Kingdom Zelda is really
just a it's a sequel you know it's going
to do a lot of what breath of the wild
did probably just bigger and better
so that's why I kind of put a little bit
of a edge to Starfield but I'm not
surprised at all that Zelda one
yo or division with the Super Chat thank
you for the amazing coverage tough
battle against Zelda for sure for sure
definitely win game of the year have a
good night everyone Mischief Managed a
or division thank you for being here and
hanging out and thank you so much for
the Super Chat as well rocker forehand 4
am here is a worth at 4am oh my gosh
yeah if it was 4 a.m for me I wouldn't
be streaming
I get even if they showed a trailer you
know I could watch it in the morning so
it is about uh it is almost 10 p.m so we
are coming up on the two hour mark of
the official show they start at 7 30 p.m
eastern time was the pre-show
and so it's been two and a half hours
since then now we are shifting into
I think James said that uh Jeff Keeley
said it was going to be around two and a
half hours
I was hoping it would only be around two
hours but yeah how are you so I think we
might have another half an hour
house racket tour welcomes all
welcome welcome members of house
recorder Trevor Morris with the tier one
Trevor thank you so much
for becoming a channel member and
becoming a member of House rack and tour
this looks interesting
all right
let's get lucky so yeah we got half an
hour left
I don't think they would end with
Hogwarts Legacy so I feel like if we
don't see something in the next
10 to 15 minutes I don't think we'll see
anything tonight sadly sadly
Transformers reactivate interesting
very interesting coming up Animal from
the Muppets drops by and Keegan Michael
Key shares a new look at the Super Mario
Brothers movie oh I do want to see that
the award for best game Direction stick
around
all right James I'm losing hope of
anything new yeah I just did a poll in
chat and like 61 said no we're not
getting a trailer yeah yeah if you were
right about the two and a half hours we
got about what half an hour left yeah
you know they're not gonna end with that
so no yeah there's no way so it would
have to be within the next 10 15 minutes
max I think that's that's exactly what I
said okay
yeah so if we don't get anything after
that definitely not but I'm still want
to see who gets game of the year though
oh the Elder ring hasn't won anything I
don't think
they got they got one I can't remember
what it was though art art oh art yeah I
think so I think you're right I think
you're right yeah they did get that one
they get that one
but yeah and Garson narrative or voice
acting or story and stuff they haven't
won any even audio
I think they were up for audio and they
didn't get it yeah I think God of War
got the audio
yeah so I think
um is going to oh what is this
they got to get game of the year
this looks good
interesting
first person
the strength of your resolve Gladiator
is the only thing that crunch of the day
it's probably something already
announced that
I don't think I've seen it
this place is relentless
it devours everything
I'm so
and soon it will take you Sky dances JJ
Abrams
[Music]
yo
what
oh my gosh
oh my gosh
oh my
God what is that brush the humor or
behemoth yeah what I say be emblem
yo that looks like a fun game to do a VR
yeah that looks like it all right I will
play that
enough for VR whether the beans
yeah Skyrim Elder Scrolls Vibes for sure
chat for sure I'm back welcome back
Maddie That's crazy dude Fall Guys joint
stream could be fun
oh such a good call retro oh my gosh
like on a Saturday or like late at night
or something oh my God that could be a
lot of fun yes chat how would you guys
feel about a Fall Guys yo I'm down you
got to get like the whole Community like
last Marauders Lynette like yeah you
could party up with like I think you can
get four people in there yeah yeah oh
here's the Mario let's go yes yes yes
okay
love him
this is so great that we can all be
all having such a good time that laugh
just sounded like toads
yes yes please
I played the game for a bit when I went
free to play it's fun it's a fun game
well something about
um Toad's head
you would be right uh because I see a
lot of people online saying that it's a
hat and and you know what it's not a hat
it's a cap
you see because the cap is that top part
of the mushroom that houses the spores
and everything and also a cap
is another word for hat right what is
happening okay just right now Zach yo
um oh wait Jake wow Jake two minutes ago
Jake I missed you my man so sorry Jake
with the Super Chat Retron popping off
tell James I said I I'm still surprised
Starfield is coming to Xbox might hop on
later though Jake thank you so much
thank you for the Super Chat and then
Zach coming in with the Super Chat as
well found you this week thanks for all
the Hogwarts Legacy content hey Zach
thank you so much my friend
thank you so much oh dude here we go we
caught it we caught it
that looks absolutely I mean he could be
backstage for Amy
yes I like the energy as you can see I'm
now joined by animal from the upcoming
Muppets Mayhem uh say hi animal
why are you sneaking according to Eric's
Twitter
the game awards I love this enthusiasm
animal so I have to ask what do you want
to play do you have a certain game or uh
tonist
I didn't imagine you being a soulsborne
player
do you have a favorite boss in Elder
gray Eric didn't say it was backstage
you're still thinking about it she's so
pretty tough in the game uh well now
that I know you're such a big game fan
have you ever thought about kind of
appearing in your own game or having an
animal game oh yeah yeah because
[Applause]
Zachary Morris yeah what is up man retro
can I get a shout out to my daughter
like you do with Alex podcast now Chloe
Morris hey for sure Zach what's up Chloe
games Chloe watch the streams too
uh animal
Crossing
I know right Zach we got a Zachary
Morris in the house anyways yeah Zachary
regularly stops by me thanks for the
Super Chat Zachary
oh yeah dude I thought they were gonna
[Music]
[Applause]
look the best score and music
[Music]
oh best score in music okay
always some of you guys aren't feeling
the CR I don't mind the Chris Pratt
voice I don't mind it
and Jack Black as Bowser oh my gosh
he nailed that
okay what was this one music
Chandler that group probably
like oh we lost we're out game award for
goes to
God of War Ragnarok Ragnarok again
God of War games do have some really
good music
[Applause]
congratulations
Jeff is such a huge fan of The Muppets
[Applause]
I literally don't believe it uh no thank
you so much everybody
um but I really got to give a shout out
to everybody at Santa Monica Studio
Corey
when you told me this story eight years
yeah
another God of War Victory I'm telling
you that's four
so I don't know if Williams I don't know
if you're aware yet uh retro uh Eric all
musicians posted a tweet saying game
awards boys he's with the crew yeah and
he shows pictures Chandler's off doing
hot girl
um stuff I saw that yeah yeah okay so
they were like okay Izzy backstage is he
gone
people were in my chat were saying he's
backstage
yeah and somebody said maybe he just
left after that they didn't win yeah he
probably just went to the bathroom we
got a lot of my chat saying he just went
potty
for everybody
thank you so much oh my gosh
but yeah I uh yeah we still got six
seven minutes before I call it
congratulations there and now it's time
for an exclusive reveal of a brand new
action RPG developed by the creators of
life is strange
no they said all the keywords oh we were
so close
action RPG
oh God I could feel I I thought that was
it I really did yeah because you just
said we got about five six minutes
before I call it
Nico says Chandler is actually animal
I'll be tearing on the side this looks
interesting though right right did Sue
turn in or Sue's still there yeah oh she
said uh she did say bye oh sorry that
must have been on mute yeah no you're
good she wasn't gonna last too long
oh
[ __ ]
I'm saying a ghost myself
that's a good point Timothy he said his
life is life is strange an action game
it is not it's a different a different
game by the people who made like it made
the game yeah yeah looks good kill him
it does
foreign
oh come on
he said an upcoming action RPG
from the creators of
life is strange
no no
10 P.M
what's up James what's up Harry Potter
good to see you Chandler's behind this
we did get anything
don't call and expect that guy I won't
call it right I always love that name
Harry Potter
yeah yeah
he's great this is United group oh is
this gameplay
looks like it
oh let's go
so yo I might play that right when they
get to the good part
we
are the defense
we got a lot of plays for that previous
one
yeah I'd play that fight that last one
oh my gosh
looks like a modern Gears of War or
something I know
hey thanks
uh James thank you so much for streaming
the game awards live crazy here trying
to edit videos enjoy myself while
watching you and retro so you got some
love retro from the aura division nice
so you guys fellow Hogwarts Legacy
content critic or show some love awesome
yeah I got Warhammer Vibes Too Delirious
you can always hope more it's true
my phone is about to die Brett last last
hold on just hold on Rhett
two more months for Hogwarts lazy yep
two more months that is just crazy right
oh it's Tuesday
Tuesday was the day we you guys uh
predicted or the sixth uh I know
somebody pointed that out I had
completely forgotten about that me too I
I also forgot that was the day when
Chandler started and made his
announcement that he was the community
manager too a year ago
I was just like wow
all right so if not here and I know you
you did the Showcase so if you know
something and can't say it's all good if
you had to guess when do you feel like
the next big thing might be from them
uh either before Christmas or January I
think so too I feel like something
before the new year
so like I'm thinking either like next
because they did my showcase on a Friday
so and like one day notice so this could
happen at any moment yes guys yes but
they are gone
the crew is right now yeah so
they might be on chill mode finishing up
stuff before the holidays and then get
something in January could be
because I think obviously the end of
December is going to be slow
um just because everybody's celebrating
the holiday and stuff and you know
people travel not everybody lives in
Salt Lake City and stuff over at
Avalanche software so
um yeah I think they might take a break
since Christmas is on a Sunday
um we still got a good solid two weeks
possibly
um before they go on like Christmas
break maybe a week and a half so I think
twitch is celebrating nothing in between
16th and like the 23rd
over blood which was I was hoping for
they did the fall ASMR on Thanksgiving
maybe Christmas is the winter ASMR yeah
that'd be like a turnover time in like a
month that would be a quick turnaround
yeah we don't have that much time before
the game comes out
all right we'll be right back because
yeah I mean once February like once
February's here that's it that's it's
here exactly exactly because like you're
gonna start getting what reviews of the
game
ASMR so you're gonna start getting
reviews of the game mid-January I want
to say late mid to late January between
that window before the beginning of
February
um
so
yeah I'm thinking like early January
when they get back
or before the 25th
we're we're weeks from it going gold at
this point I'm like honestly I think
within the next four to six weeks we're
gonna get an announcement as gold
[Music]
December 8th yeah so it could be four to
six weeks yep I think you nailed it so
about a month yep yep yep a month or two
give or take them coming back from the
Christmas holiday in the new year
back at it checking fine-tuning things
and then they gotta start localizing the
localization producer start making sure
everything is available for all the
regions that the game's coming out in
regards to marketing and
um whatever other trailers you probably
get like a smart a small mini mini
trailer announcing the games coming out
like next week or something or whatever
two weeks and then
we're in it like the game is going to be
here so like it's going to be silent
Sports
yeah right right
like I I I I made a post like a couple a
month or two ago like saying like yo
enjoy the ride
you don't know when it's gonna happen
again everybody took it like is the game
going to be canceled I was like no I'm
just saying enjoy this feeling that you
have the feeling of anticipation because
like yo
there's not going to be another first
Hogwarts Legacy now the next Hogwarts
Legacy game is going to be based off of
what the first one did but this is the
very first of its kind this is a big
deal and so after a year of Silence in
2021 and then getting all of this in
2022. enjoy the momentum the excitement
and how it all came together this year
welcome right before the house thank you
everything so
yeah I know you saw the video I made
like a whole video just about like that
exactly yes concept
my hobby
I love Crash Bandicoot all right so what
do you think they always end with
something big I feel like it's Elder
ring DLC if I had to guess
yeah yeah
I hope it's something big though what
actor though hmm because I feel like
they bring out a big actor yeah true
oh my gosh announcing the Elder ring
yeah yeah
what happened we were supposed to meet
up here and steal all the bumper fruit
from the game awards which I'm now
realizing was
oh excuse me is it not exclusive to
PlayStation anymore nah I think they've
been
because I think it's Activision now
okay so that's with uh Xbox whatever
well they're still with anybody right
now but
oh it says captured on PS5 so I guess
this one's at least still
yeah
they got a fighting game smash like what
dude PlayStation All-Stars should have
had a sequel that was a great first
attempt it was
it
was
the characters
is this a fighting game or is it I don't
know there's a lot of trailer stuff but
no gameplay
a pursuit of fruit or the fruit what is
it just a mobile game
this is a Mario party I could maybe
that's what it is
crash team Rumble whoa
what now please welcome two outstanding
content creator and streamers uh-oh did
we have another bot did elwin or Nico
have to Nuke another bot for us
against the fastest and furthest it's
Innovation and accessibility each year
designers impress oh yeah this is
there's been a lot more enhancement in
this yep yep
very important marginalized here are the
Game Awards nominees for Innovation and
accessibility
Innovation and accessibility it's a
single player and multiplayer experience
we want to draw in people who weren't
necessarily Gamers
that's right yeah
I forgot they did that
book for guidance that Suite of features
I know The Last of Us Part Two kind of
like really set the bar for
accessibility and games I saw something
where there was a guy who in the game
it's a game that can be beaten by
somebody completely blind
which is amazing that is awesome
God of work yo yo that's five
that's awesome
that's awesome yeah yo they got the
captive uh Marvel bag that's awesome
[Applause]
Ellen's leading Bots left and right what
is it about the Bots tonight maybe it's
like the game awards thing there you go
I don't know
and also
I set this one up slightly different
than I normally do
because it's not uh normally we had to
do a Hogwarts stream it's just like I
just copy everything over change the
title this one I did is a completely
accessibility features happen oh my gosh
is that Wonder Woman we're trying to
make these features it's not the it's
not the Wonder Woman
symbol though on that side
the UI ux team and everyone who made it
possible uh I can't thank you enough and
I think that the the players yeah thanks
for the Super Chat Nico and Elwyn thank
you
I need to give Elwyn uh Ellen has the
band Hammer tonight all games have no
limits clearing out the Bots
appreciate the support but feel free to
use the emotes and access to behind the
scenes and discount on merch
I have an uncle James who has cerebral
palsy and when I was we were growing up
he would play
like he only has control of when he said
I agree Jerry agreed oh I was muted
so James I have an uncle who has
cerebral palsy and so he only has like
use of one hand basically and we were
growing up we would play games all the
time because he like the original
Nintendo how he would play he would put
it like flat on the ground beside him
and then he just used this one hand to
play smart smart it's like typing yeah
yeah and so he it got a lot harder for
him when they started adding the uh like
the shoulder buttons and stuff yep yep
still somehow he manages to do it that's
awesome
yo there it's so cool to see these games
like taking strides and that and making
excessive accessible to like so many
like that's so cool
yeah gosh
that's awesome
I don't know about you but I've had so
many Bots tonight elwin's having to just
like ban left and right clean out the
Bots yo we're reaching a water audience
tonight because of the game awards it
could be like the hashtags and stuff
yeah yeah so
um we're not in a safe little bubble
within the August the community
all right shout out to all the mods
handling business
oh my gosh
you guys are Lifesavers you already know
and now from 505
. all right I'm about ready to call it I
don't think it's we got five minutes
yeah all right yeah
Miko said wait you're getting paid ill
oh I wish I could pay you mods I I know
seriously
we are here to set a slightly different
tone for the trailer you're about to
watch
you see this trailer here well
a little different than the rest of
these trailers you're seeing tonight
this one's a little bit dangerous
so the boss wanted to come out here you
know make sure you don't hurt yourself
sometime during the next 60 Seconds
wow no trailer Larry the crowd no
trailer tonight
I don't I don't think we're gonna get
one ah what a knife wow at first I
thought maybe
listen I uh
I've had some wild times uh I've been
involved in some crazy things in my life
sounds like answer with Mr Al Pacino
Donnie Brasco game over man I know I
think I think it's uh
Men In Black maybe I have to say being
the Crime Boss of Rocket City
now that's a lot of fun
and uh we've got an amazing cast with us
these two handsome guys with me
you've been Nico are going to drive the
school crazy we ravenclaws will have to
choose between helping them or
destroying the new trailer for Crime
Boss Rock case City Crime Boss March
28th 2023 another March let's roll it oh
my goodness
I'm not familiar with this
any of you guys heard of this or is this
totally like
First Look Crime Boss
Rock a city okay I couldn't understand
what they're saying
[Music]
I mean GTA clone they're definitely
going after the GTA
audience for sure elwin not not a clue
Ryan nope yeah I hadn't heard of it
either
Danny Glover has gloves
I knew that was Michael Rooker it looked
Vanilla Ice this is okay what
Chuck Norris
are you kidding me
what I'm buying it just because of Chuck
Norris
oh my gosh
here are the nominees Final Fantasy 16
must be the last trailer yeah
Pokemon Legends Arceus oh gotta be yeah
yeah Xenoblade Chronicles three
more yeah
Alden ring congratulations yeah
that's like two three maybe
four voted categories so this is the
only one oh I bet Sonic Sonic a lot of
people were trying to vote for Sonic
at Eldon ring God of War Elder ring
because not everybody played God of War
not everybody has a PlayStation could be
could be elderly
wow wow
goes to stray congratulations yeah yeah
and the game award goes to
God of War yo Tim thank you dude good to
see you yes right there having a good
night
they are cleaning up yes welcome to
patrol the squad thanks for the support
ongoing game Final Fantasy 14 or
fortnite I was gonna say final because
it won that earlier oh yeah the
community joint yep yeah
wow the engine impact was a huge upset
all right I feel like we're in the home
stretch now yeah probably like the last
little commercial type break because
what's his name went over at the
beginning yeah
yeah because yeah it's almost 10 30 now
yeah
hey everybody uh on both streams chat
thanks for holding it down you guys have
been awesome thanks for interacting with
retro and myself this has been a fun
stream this is the first time we're
trying this so thanks for uh being
patient with us and stuff
yeah it definitely made it go by faster
having somebody to talk to since we
didn't yeah we haven't gotten anything
that we really wanted to want it no no
no but I think just doing stuff like
this with everybody is the best part so
yeah
gosh oh but we were talking about games
to possibly play have you ever done like
a Jack box night with your extreme yeah
those are so good yeah
um we got we started doing it based off
Lynnette and uh we've tried it a couple
of times
um Cindy in our Discord Host Game stuff
on on Saturdays I need to join if I
wasn't just so crazy but yeah I just
need to get into it you don't have to
actually people can play without owning
the game it's like I just have it I
fired up on stream people can
get in and play yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
agreed
Machop says we need to do a podcast
hey you never know about shop
Doritos never know I know there's
already another August Lacey podcast so
we could just do Gryffindor and
Hufflepuff podcast and just call it a
day
Jalen I could definitely do a podcast
like it didn't even have to be Wizarding
World I feel like just talking yeah yeah
for sure Marvel snap Greenland and
thanks for the one month
and again kamcho thanks for joining
the Multiverse here's a clip of hero any
I doubt I just downloaded this game like
this week I've heard I need to get it
yeah
because this is something you play on uh
during a stream too like just casually
yeah is that like mobile games you could
just stream I I have a um Android my
Samsung and it once I connected to my PC
it turns into my screen turns into the
PC or my PC turns into nice and so like
I can just stream like right there
so he screaming I had to figure out how
to stream mobile games obviously with
Wizards unite so it's it's a lot easier
yeah uh than consoles especially with
capture cards and stuff you have to deal
with
oh so you don't even need a capture card
for it no no no
that iPhone makes it difficult it
probably always
yeah I just plug in my USBC
um
to the computer and boom nice
scared you now scare James get wait
scare James also I better be your
favorite Noob favorite new what does
that mean I think you're the only Noob
we have here
you better be staying hydrated Noob
thank you so much for the Super Chat
can't believe Noob just said roar I know
it sounds like uh remember Rex from Toy
Story
were you scared
do that I was close to being scared that
time Usher that experience I was close
to being scared that time
I got ten dollars every time somebody
scared me my wife is so very easily I
have a very light steps she tells me so
like she'll be in a different room of
the house and I'll just sneak up on her
out of nowhere every December just like
freaks are out not even like not
intentionally
that I know something Reggie let's go
there it is everybody loves Reggie
everybody
so sorry Marco I can't say anything
[Applause]
so this year I'm here to present agree
Rebecca let's get his little pin he's
got the pen up on his uh particularly
early sighting award especially is that
him
I think it's him constantly maybe it's
mystery wada who passed away at Nintendo
Innovation and artistry
as to be nominated
you need to have created an experience
that is incredibly who says Roar anymore
to the teams I don't know if I've ever
typed out Roar you have my utmost
respect I don't know
here are the nominees for the best metro
fight four oh my gosh I would lose it he
doesn't work at Nintendo anymore though
he retired
he's just there as a uh you know as a
video gaming fan
best art direction oh
this is another tough one I Gotta Wear
ragnarok's but cleaning up so you gotta
feel like they're the front runner
but Elden ring I feel like I wouldn't be
surprised if they got it either I mean
the way things have been going tonight
God of War is definitely gonna win more
Awards the question is will it win the
big the game of the year award and the
game Award for best game Direction goes
to
there we go
that's that's probably their biggest one
so far the other one was something with
art I think
Noob has created a raw Army a moon Lily
got the emo going there
I don't know why I always say emote I
feel like everybody else just says emote
but I'm always like eat where we'll know
when it comes to Emoji I just say Emoji
why do I say emotes
right
a great pleasure receiving this such a
wonderful Miyazaki dude
a man makes some incredible games
I'm very honored about that
[Music]
Timothy
yeah Ireland is our you know um the
biggest game that we have ever worked on
um so we have worked with uh several
code electors including I'm still
calling Elder ring DLC as the
um is how they end the show support
um it's it's my prediction it will be
almost impossible to you know um finish
working on this project
um so we really want to share this yes
the art right the art in that game is
incredible Mr Moe incredible
I mean just some of the bosses
like like the mind and Imagination to
create once again thank you so much for
your support some of those bosses Neil
you've only ever heard His email okay
maybe it's not just me then
maybe it's not just me
World premiere
darn it how many times you willing to
get burned before you stop trusting
somebody else
sometimes you can just tell right away
it's not Hogwarts yep
technology what
ah
politicians yeah Runners intelligence
elderly deserved that that yeah
there's anyone we can trust now it's him
Solomon Reeve
I wonder if cyberpunk is finally in a
good State it's a play oh it sounds like
it
a simple choice
them for us
peace
Noob scared me scared you nice scared me
no
he said that yeah I could figure out if
he scared you or what yeah he was a war
hey it's just Alba agent Solomon Reed in
cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty oh cool
for you guys to meet trade when Phantom
Liberty releases in 2023
it looks good that mocap yeah
awesome I loved how you guys asked if
you got to put on the no cash account
yeah yeah
I wish I did see this setup but uh
okay each of its releases this studio
nominated
times
and I am grateful that they have chosen
the game awards as the place for This
Global Last of Us multiplayer
dude Jeff is like emotional about this
yeah
oh oh come on no
it's bloodborne too I'm gonna lose it
doesn't sound like bloodborne 2 Guys
doesn't look like bloodborne too darn it
okay okay I'm getting like a few more
futuristic that's why I said no to
bloodborne
Matt bandai's not Mass Effect are they
[Music]
is it Mass Effect
come on chat come on you guys need to
figure it out before me code vein two
I think it's a Souls game feed the fire
okay now definitely not like bloodborne
sounds like Souls dude but it doesn't
look like like let the Cinders burn
[Music]
what is this
armored Core
no it's a new armored Core game
what
I was like okay it's way too futuristic
I never played armor core so
I don't know whether to be excited or
not I know from software makes great
games
I may have played
I'm pretty sure I played a demo of armor
core back on PlayStation
Daniel hey Daniel thank you for
subscribing to the channel welcome
welcome
oh my gosh
armored Core six fires of Rubicon
and new with the five gifteds
my mind did you play armor core games
yes oh yes I did I love them growing up
yeah it looks amazing from software
I'll try it because I've been so
impressed with their other stuff yeah
oh new trailer wait more Mario welcome
to Griffins
more Mario
um
dude I love all the references in this
game
has arrived in the Mushroom Kingdom do
You Know It music I know every human
being with a mustache
we've seen bits of this
great APG for action and Mild violence
wait what's happening after no
how are you congrats to those of you who
just got a gifted membership
from noob
you are now a member of House raconteur
welcome
to house rack and tour skin well I
thought we were in the final stretch but
looks like another commercial
yo I think the
the early video
yeah
yeah as Keeley said like
2.5 hours
yeah we're right at the
well we're over two and a half now yeah
yeah we're just over
technically over three when you count
the pre-show pre-show exactly yup yup
agreed
are all connected
it is such a tough spot to be in because
he does have to like you said he has to
pay for it somehow yeah so they have to
do some of the ads but yeah yeah man
three hours is so long
yo for nothing you're right let's be
honest let's be honest like most of
these games are opportunities for
developers you know to Showcase their
games and they on a big stage and I re I
like that's what's up but there's a
reason a lot of people play
the most popular games and why they are
so many remakes because people enjoy
playing those so right it sucks for you
know ooh Lo-Fi I love that
um I know that YouTube channel yeah yeah
listen to them all the time yes yes
but yeah not a lot of games people are
at least General audience would be
interested in
I've been in my I have a sit stand desk
I've been at standing the whole time for
this one foreign
I love it I need one I just got it last
year and I researched them well not like
this year but early in the year yeah and
I really researched it a lot because
it's great like just being able to have
because a lot of people think you just
are gonna stand all the time but that's
not how they're supposed to be used just
like it's the moment you start to feel a
little back pain you can just hop up sit
down yeah I do it a lot when I Video
Edit like I'll be I'll do my recording
or something sitting down and then when
I get to do the editing I'll stand up or
or vice versa you know yeah yeah I love
that I literally have like a dining room
table as my desk oh wow from Kia yeah
this thing is like belong
because I need it for like so much stuff
I do especially with sketching before I
do my designs and finally by his fans of
sushi P thanks everyone thanks for the
kind words role-playing game Final
Fantasy 14 winner of two game awards
Patty foot I want a membership too
all right let's see if this works Final
Fantasy 16
please join me in welcoming for the
first time oh come on Mr now okay the
Alias you set this command to be of
exclamation point member does not exist
wait what
all right I need to fix that one Nico
I need to fix the exclamation point join
Alias you set the screen Final Fantasy
16 teams let's see I'm on up see if this
works to present you
with tonight nope
World premiere
final World premiere
it's gonna be Final Fantasy something
first two cookie I love it I love it
Final Fantasy yo here we go dude a lot
of people excited for this one
a lot of people excited for this one
okay if discord's not working we know
something messed up because okay well
that one's still working all right
this is literally my first time seeing
anything about the new
Final Fantasy oh let me turn up the
sound for you guys
thank you
I'm intrigued I'm intrigued Revenge is a
weapon
weapon I sometimes wonder if I am
controlling it or if it's controlling me
yeah I think that one's broken noob
let me try spoilers
okay so it's it seems like it's a
problem with anything that I've set an
alias for
that's the problem Atomic dudman yeah
still going they said they were gonna be
shorter this year
we're getting up on the three hour mark
closing in on the three hour mark
and not a thing for Hogwarts I guess
not a thing for it volte with another
Super Chat you think about the Discord
what
what'd you do volte
what'd you do to the Discord
thanks for the support volte appreciate
it
appreciate you hanging out
a wizard
you're a wizard Harry
Breezy welcome to the channel thank you
for subscribing
dude I haven't played a final fantasy in
a long time but this looks really good
this looks really good
might have to jump back in
trying to think of the last one I played
[Applause]
I played nine I did I've never played
ten
the last final was nine the last final
fantasy in my place flight Studios
Game of the Year winner for it takes two
no way this is
yo Apple
actually it feels really good thank you
so much for the subscription or no you
are now a member so of house raconteur
my friends yeah
it's like what what did you do to the
Discord fantastic saw
Nico basically built our Discord as it
is now great feeling
but however you do he's gonna do that
I mean I was sitting over there and
trust me the hair all hair or my body
was all over the place no uh Goose pump
I mean it's really awesome so we got
what you meant don't worry
[Applause]
oh here we go gave me here
game of the year
it's been too long man
[Music]
all right here we go finally yeah
Game of the Year let's go
I love Kingdom Hearts Logan we're
talking about Phantom fantasy over here
ah wrong chat Ryan I think Ryan meant
this message for you he said James don't
know if you saw my post regarding
PlayStation store Jedi Survivor is now
available for pre-orders
oh I'm doing that right after the Stream
all right chat both chats get your final
predictions in yes yes it's gonna take
it home let's put up a quick poll
I'm still saying Eldon ring me too but I
wouldn't be surprised with Ragnarok
either yeah
I'm just gonna put two
Ragnarok there's no there's no other
choices
all right it's yeah I don't feel like
the speed the speech was a little long
but no way it threw him off this much no
these asses was getting in the way yeah
yeah all right I got the coal up what is
your chat looking like this thing uh we
didn't do a poll but looks like mostly
Elder ring got a couple God of War but
mostly Eldon ring mostly Elder ring okay
all right we're kind of mixed over here
uh great Point by Stargazer Tim can't be
disappointed either way both great games
agree agreed uh Trent said he voted for
Horizon uh just because
uh yeah I guess they enjoyed it Horizon
just came out at a bad time more God of
War people so Elder ring was leading
early in my chat now more it's probably
about even now yeah oh shoot do you do
it what's your poll yeah all right let's
pull looking like uh we got 200 votes oh
57 God of War 43 elderly it's close out
of 200 votes
no you didn't miss it Jace they didn't
reveal anything
maybe next year
uh God of War winning but next year is
between Hogwarts Legacy and Spider-Man
yo I think Zelda yo is gonna be up there
yeah yeah Zelda Spider-Man and
definitely Hogwarts Lake and probably
Starfield if it star field too yesterday
I forgot about that yeah
yep
God that's some stiff competition
right
they have competition
[Music]
uh VBS I've done some streams
oh wait are we about to find out though
hold on hold on
it's got to be Elder ring
that was all people were talking about
if it's not eldering I feel like it is
purely
not the god of war is not exactly
exactly like if you flip them if the
Elder ring just came out there's no way
people would be seeing God of War
exactly and I love God of War I mean
I've got the hammer right here guys I
love it
let's see though
there you go winner is he already looked
Elder ring there we go there we go there
we go there we go it's it's one of my
favorite games ever I loved it really
yeah
I got the platinum trophy in it
I just
it's it's yeah I'm a sucker for those
kinds of games what's crazy is it took
me a while to really get into them like
I first tried Demon Souls I was like oh
my gosh I hate this and then it was the
third try of demon souls I finally it
finally clicked and then I just love
like I played all of them sold all the
souls bloodborne
yeah well dessert well who's the young
kid thank you so much I don't know
yeah I think so Nico
I think they got it right
but I still haven't played ready to rock
and I know I love Ryan I know I will
soon
ring Draco I'm trying to get it on
I would like to share this great
appreciation oh you may you've retracted
it I bet it's everything yeah on Elden
ring but I want to get it on gotta work
partner Banda and Amco Oracle Library I
just finished off the Valkyries so in
the first game the 2018.
oh I love it Jordan I love the challenge
that's one of my like if I don't have if
I'm not challenged in games it's really
hard for me to have a good time I gotta
have some kind of challenge I mean
that's honestly like the challenge is
ultimately why I play games
I know a lot of people it's story but
for me I choose gameplay over story any
day any day
we have faced so many difficulties while
developing this game so as of the
elector I'm really relieved
and this might not be really you know
like thing to say made to type elderly
yeah I figured so
um receiving the goatee award but I
haven't made up my mind to create even
more interesting games than this one
all right now they're going to end it
with uh
hopefully more before the end of the
year Zach I think so I think we'll get
something we still have
several more things we want to do yes
getting this Cody award let's go come on
reveal some of it right now
reveal it right now let's go
I'll tell you
um
yeah Jordan for some people that is fun
though
and I don't think they do it to
intentionally make you mad I think they
do it for you to learn and to be
strategic it's not Button Mash like the
old you play an old school God of War
game and then you jump into Souls game
yeah you're gonna hate it
it's just not how you can play it
you
know
at most gratitude to
fans uh for played if we enjoy them who
supported this title that that's
satisfaction and we use that
satisfaction dude when you finally
overcome the challenge
um oh so much it makes it so worth it
hey Martin
you know real quick I want to thank
everybody and say that I think I want to
nominate this award to my reformed
Orthodox Rabbi Bill Clinton thank you
everybody
wait who is that dude is that like
security up there
all right was he not supposed to be up
there the vet believe me congratulations
this has been such a special night and I
can't believe wait was that kid not
supposed to be up there oh no it looked
like it lucky to do this that was Secure
to yourself for support I know all of
you around the world viewers I thought
it was like one of their kids or
something special announcement from us
to celebrate our 10th year the game
awards is thrilled to be partnering with
the LA Phil it's been nice video game
music live at the world's famous
Hollywood Bowl next one definitely
wasn't it definitely wasn't this big
five years ago past decade of video game
music and looking at it thank you
there's no other big
announcements
so I guess Final Fantasy was kind of
their big uh and happy holidays and
we'll see you yeah in 2023. that's
everybody I know
yeah shout out and yeah no DLC or
nothing oh
thanks for subscribing Christian
s Love From Italy yo
everyone clap to this I bet it's going
viral as you speak did he say Bill
I don't think so Casey I was talking to
James though so I don't know
oh man
let me switch screens yep that's what I
just did too yo man this was fun
yeah yeah this was yeah we didn't get
much but hey enjoyed hanging out I
enjoyed talking hope keeping the hope
alive as long as we could and stuff this
was real good uh retro uh before we
um do our in-calls do you want to say
anything to the community over here say
hi bye yeah
oh for sure yeah yeah yeah I feel like
so many of our audience they already
know each of us yeah but if we're not
yeah at retro wrecking Tour on pretty
much Twitter YouTube uh I do have a
twitch as well haven't streamed there in
a while but yeah and same for you James
feel free to shout out your stuff oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah you already know
um latest and greatest August Legacy
content myself and Sue uh check us out
on all social medias and um I expect to
go and um all of us all the hockey Stacy
content creators just trying to keep you
guys up to date and keep the hype going
until the game's release so uh yo thanks
for having me retro and thanks for
hanging out with us over here as well
yep definitely and I mean you guys view
the chat like you keep us going we send
James and I will send messages all the
time like you know just there are
certain messages you get from people and
we get reminded all the time of just how
special this is you know what like James
was talking about this moment that we're
in leading up to the game so yeah make
sure you guys enjoy it you know we'll be
covering anything that happens you know
you guys are going to the bathroom
like he went backstage
dude can he go to the restroom
all right
I'll let you go man I'll uh we'll talk
later on sounds good see ya see you at
your bye chat see you guys see you chat
all right guys that was fun that was fun
like even though we didn't get uh we
didn't get virtually any of the
announcements we didn't get anything we
wanted
I didn't even we didn't even get Elder
ring DLC I thought that would be kind of
a
not really low hanging fruit but I
thought that was kind of likely to show
up because a lot of people have been
talking about it
oh man but it was nice hanging out with
you chat thanks for all the support all
the love
and we'll be back on Tuesday back for a
regular regularly scheduled stream we'll
see what the rest of the week holds uh I
don't know that we're gonna do streams
all the way through the holidays we are
definitely gonna do a big Christmas
celebration stream guys I'm still trying
to set the date for that it's going to
be lots of giveaways that is when you do
not want to miss so make sure you're
following if you have a Twitter follow
on Twitter at retro wrecking tour if you
don't follow on Twitter uh maybe you
have a Discord you can join our Discord
as well uh exclamation point Discord and
if you don't have either one of those
things then just make sure you're
keeping an eye on on the YouTube I'll
post it there on our community page that
we have there
mods thank you all so much
that Bill Clinton love wait did the kids
say did the kid say something about Bill
Clinton
I did what even was that like At first I
thought it was like they're a kid or a
younger brother or something
but then when he started talking the
security people started moving in
what
Pete you were over at bins wait what
like Ben snow
at his house or on the live stream
go back go watch
oh my gosh dude Rabbi Bill Clinton oh
what the heck that had to be like a day
or something
that had to be like a dare
all right unwanted commercial content or
spam
there you go
hold on no I don't want to pin that
message I want to hide user on the
channel
get out of here man dude
man dude talking about the band hammer
I gotta pull out the band Hammer tonight
guys
um Elwyn Nico Stargazer Tim any other uh
let's see who else was here I saw um
Dylan was here for a bit mods thank you
guys I'm gonna have to double triple
check next time
like I don't know why the uh the
nightbot and stuff should catch that so
there might have been something
different that I set up in the Stream
tonight we also didn't have slow mode on
so
rumor has it that kid was going to give
us Hogwarts Legacy news but Security's
like nah not happening
oh goodness Atomic dud hey thank you for
hanging out Gigi is a lobster member of
House tracking tour there's always
another day indeed we'll see what the
rest of the week brings we got
tomorrow's Friday
we'll see if they have any more posts
this week we got the jump button
announcement yesterday that was a big
deal so we'll be talking more about that
um I was kind of waiting on another
video this week because I wanted to see
if they were going to show anything
tonight so I'll have to figure out what
our next video is going to be if it's
gonna be just about the jump button or
something else I want to do a combat
breakdown too so at some point I need to
do that the last Roar stay hydrated love
the vids the content man keep up the
good work Noob as always thank you for
the love and support in the live streams
and uh all the fun you bring to the
streams Noob all the fun
and thank you for the super chats as
well
Huff above squid JP raven fire oh no
steam deck I didn't even I was watching
through twitch the whole time didn't
even have a chance but yeah maybe some
of you guys out there want a steam deck
ask if there's a swim mechanic oh well I
mean if we have an opportunity we'll
definitely ask
all right guys hey thank you all so much
for the support hope you all have a
fantastic rest of your week
um yeah man if you're not subscribed to
the channel make sure you subscribe
check us out show some love on the
recent videos and as always thank you
all so much for watching I'll talk to
you again soon
thank you
foreign